mes chers collègues à l'occasion de
l'ouverture de la session parlementaire
2022-2023 nous accueillons ce matin
Monsieur Jean-François quinco ministre
délégué chargé des Outre-mer à faire de
faire un point sur la politique du
gouvernement pour les territoires
ultramarins c'est la première fois
monsieur le ministre que notre
délégation à l'honneur de vous recevoir
donc vos fonctions actuelles et nous
vous remercions en vivement d'avoir
répondu à cette invitation nous étions
hier soir dans l'hémicycle pour le débat
relatif à la place des Outre-mer dans
notre stratégie maritime sujet sur
lequel nos collègues Annick Pétrus
Philippe folio et Marie-Laure finira
Horse ont réalisé un remarquable qui a
donné lieu à des échanges que je
qualifierais de constructif l'idée est
bien de jeter ensemble les bases de la
prochaine stratégie maritime et de
permettre que les outre-mer soient mieux
associés à sa préparation et à sa mise
en oeuvre pour plus d'efficacité on
prédécesseur Michel Magra avec coutume
de dire que les outre-mer ont besoin
d'une vision claire donc d'engagement
solide et surtout de réalisation
concrète monsieur le ministre nous
attendons en premier lieu que vous nous
livriez ce matin votre vision et vos
engagements pour nos outre-mer il y a
quelques jours vous avez commencé à
dessiner devant les députés votre
feuille de route en vue d'un renouveau
pour l'autre mère
la première ministre a annoncé pour sa
part une réunion et terminatorielle sur
les outre-mer d'ici 6 mois nous
souhaitons naturellement vous entendre
sur ces annonces et avoir des précisions
sur ces perspectives comme il s'agit
d'un échange nos collègues pourront
aussi vous faire part d'un certain
nombre de préoccupations sur la
situation dans nos territoires et sur
l'état des relations entre l'hexagone et
les outre-mer tel qu'il s'est exprimé
dans les urnes la présente audition
s'inscrit également dans le prolongement
des travaux récents ou en cours de la
délégation parmi ceux-ci j'insisterait
d'abord plus particulièrement sur la
politique du logement outre-mer qui a
fait l'objet l'an passé d'un rapport
très approfondi de nos collègues
Guillaume gantard Micheline Jacques et
Victorin Durel un sujet qui reste pour
nous une priorité dont les besoins sans
criant
autre sujet la gestion des déchets sur
laquelle nos collègues Gisèle Jourdain
et Viviane Mallet prépare un rapport ce
service public de base indissociable de
la qualité de vie et de la santé
publique dysfonctionne dans nos
territoires aux enjeux classiques de
gouvernance et de financement s'ajoute
des facteurs aggravants comme l'habitat
informel l'isolement géographique ou
encore la rareté du foncier nous
outremer nous semble encore loin
d'atteindre les objectifs de zéro déchet
et de l'économie circulaire avec toutes
les conséquences que cela implique à
l'approche du débat budgétaire j'appelle
aussi votre attention sur le travail de
fond réalisé par nos collègues
tevarovris chez Georges passion au nom
de la commission des finances portant
sur le financement de l'État en
outre-mer et sur le fond exceptionnel
d'investissement sera attentif
évidemment la traduction concrète des
ambitions affichées par le gouvernement
enfin le président du Sénat Gérard
Larcher a installé hier le groupe de
travail sur la décentralisation
avec trois objectifs principaux
travailler sur les finances locales la
déconcentration et la différenciation
j'aurai le plaisir et l'honneur de
rapporter au nom de la délégation les
travaux que notre délégation engagera la
semaine prochaine sur l'évolution
institutionnelle en outre-mer dans
l'objectif est double d'une part faire
un tour d'horizon des souhaits
d'évolution institutionnelle dans les
territoires ultramarins d'autre part
mûrir la réflexion sur une révision des
dispositions constitutionnelles
relatives à l'Outre-mer à l'occasion du
prochain cadre institutionnel de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie
sur ce point d'ailleurs monsieur le
ministre vous avez évoqué lors de
l'audition à l'Assemblée nationale la
mise en oeuvre de groupes de travail par
le gouvernement sur la même thématique
il serait intéressant pour la délégation
sans doute de connaître votre feuille de
route votre calendrier et la
méthodologie que vous allez vous allez
initier tout en sachant que la
délégation a sollicité depuis le mois de
juillet dernier l'ensemble des
collectivités d'outre-mer sur
la base des travaux menés par Michel
Magra en 2020 sur différenciation et que
nous commencerons dans la semaine
prochaine ces auditions avec ma Cora
porteur missing Jack que je salue
aujourd'hui afin de pouvoir opérer un
livrable d'ici la fin de l'année sur des
évolutions possibles et je vous rejoins
sur un sujet c'est que ces évolutions
doivent avant tout répondre aux besoins
de nos concitoyens et des collectivités
dans le pilotage des politiques
publiques je ne serai pas plus long
encore tous mes remerciements pour votre
présence je précise que la présence
audition fait l'objet d'une captation
vidéo retransmise en direct sur le site
interne net du Sénat et qu'elle sera
consultable en vidéo à la demande je
vous souhaite la parole monsieur le
ministre pour votre exposé liminaire je
ne doute pas que mes collègues auront
ensuite de nombreuses questions à vous
poser
sur le président Artano merci de
m'accueillir madame messieurs les
sénateurs merci
d'accepter de m'écouter
je pense que la plupart d'entre nous
nous connaissons maintenant j'étais hier
en séance publique sur l'excellent
rapport que vous avez fait sur la place
des Outre-mer dans la stratégie Martine
nationale et j'ai pris l'engagement et
je le tiens de recevoir un par un tous
les parlementaires
de l'outre-mer certains l'ont déjà été
reçus essayer de dialoguer en vrai donc
je m'excuse auprès de ceux qui m'ont
déjà entendu mais je pense qu'il est
toujours bon ne fait résonner ce message
auquel je crois pour que ce message
j'allais dire Rico j'en ai moins de
recoins de nos institutions
et pour qu'il devienne aussi commun que
le son des cloches de l'église au milieu
du village il faut remettre l'outre-mer
au milieu du village ce message est le
suivant
les outre-mer ne sont pas une charge
mais une chance pour la France et la
France n'est pas une contrainte mais une
chance absolue pour l'outre-mer
être fusionnel
et pour que cette réalité soit visible
en quotidien ne compatriotes de ce que
j'appelle dorénavant l'archipel France
ne Marie pas sous la Tahiti de Mamoudzou
à Saint-Pierre de Fort-de-France à
Nouméa de Pointe-à-Pitre à Wallis et on
peut faire d'autres diagonales
de l'action il nous faut créer de la
valeur créer de la valeur ça sera mon
leitmotiv rue Oudinot et au sein du
gouvernement et auprès de tous ceux que
je rencontre créer de la valeur
économique créer de la valeur culturelle
j'insiste sur ce sujet qui est le
des moteurs de l'action
crée de la valeur sociale sortir des
immobilismes renouer le dialogue
co-construire les solutions concrètes on
peut avoir de grands rapports qui
situent les enjeux mais derrière il faut
des actions concrètes au quotidien pour
cela le président de la République et la
première ministre et comme c'est la
première fois que je viens de cette
assemblée
délégation je vais la rappeler le
président de la République la première
ministre ont choisi de rattacher les
outre-mer en ministère de l'Intérieur de
temps en temps
plutôt à l'Assemblée qu'au Sénat
j'entends dire que c'est une catastrophe
je le dis c'est pas une quelconque
punition et une relégation tous ceux qui
disent ça raconte des sornettes il me
semble au contraire que pour remettre
les outre-mer au troisième rang
protocolaire dans le gouvernement pour
démultiplier l'action pour gagner les
arbitrages pour établir nos drones comme
dans le périmètre ministériel des
collectivités de la citoyenneté de
l'ordre public de la sécurité intérieure
des libertés publiques de
l'administration territoriale de l'État
de l'immigration de l'asile et de
l'intégration c'est ce qu'il fallait
faire
en réalité pour remettre les outre-mer
sur un pied d'égalité avec les autres
régions de l'Hexagone une manière très
pratique cette attelage me semble
efficace mais réunions
interministérielles avec Gérald Darmanin
se résume un coup de fil et je vais au
rime avec les autres forts de l'appui
d'aminister au 300000 agents
néanmoins
les outre-mer ont des enjeux spécifiques
que nous ne connaît pas la France
continentale
insularité éloignement plus grande
précarité d'une partie de la population
vulnérabilité climatique plus forte
hexagonales c'est pour cela que je suis
là je pense que je veux y dédier ma
force mon énergie et un peu d'expérience
moi qui commence à avoir de l'âge
Gérald Darmanin m'a signé pour cela une
feuille de route je viens de la donner
à votre président comme il se doit
et je pourrais détailler dans nos
échanges mais aussi le résumé de ce
qu'elle propose premièrement répondre
concrètement au préoccupations
quotidiennes des citoyens sans réponse à
ses préoccupations quotidiennes c'est la
cohésion je dirais pas sociale c'est pas
la cohésion sociétale
qui est en riche je pense à la vie chère
à l'eau au chlore des cônes Sargasses
aux déchets à la continuité territoriale
au logement à la santé
au-delà des philosophies globales sur
lesquels il peut y avoir des désaccords
il y a un certain nombre d'actions
concrètes qu'il nous faut mener sans
attendre et avec les services du
ministère mais en liaison aussi avec
tous les ministères c'est ce qu'apporte
le rattachement du ministère de
l'Outre-mer au ministère de l'Intérieur
cette force
auprès des de mes collègues et des
administrations des autres ministères il
nous faut travailler deuxième
préoccupation
renforcer l'ambition républicaine pour
par et grâce et bien dit pour par et
grâce aux habitants des territoires
ultramarins ça veut dire effort sur la
sécurité sur l'immigration sur la
formation sur l'éducation c'est les
trois les quatre sujets extrêmement
lourds
troisième sujet favoriser la création de
valeur qui seul permet à la jeunesse
ultra-marine
d'avoir une vie possible dans les années
qui viennent ça veut dire culture je
l'ai dit mais transformations des
modèles économiques en outre-mer
renforcement de la production agricole
locale transition énergétique nouveau
contrat de plan et planification des
investissements nécessaires qui se
chiffre dans mon esprit à 30 milliards
d'outre-mer donc mettons-les par écrit
ça et puis on pourra travailler et
avancer
ça me paraît indispensable
quatrième sujet agir pour l'adaptation
la différenciation la responsabilisation
des acteurs
je pense qu'il y aura des questions
là-dessus mais à ces questions j'ai
rajouté celle d'énormes françaises
européennes et j'y rajoute le réflexe
législatif outre-mer c'est vous les
législateurs c'est pas l'exécutif
imaginez que je dis ce que vous devez
faire non pas oui je vais le dire quand
même
il faut que chaque texte me semble-t-il
prévoit une possibilité d'adaptation
que vous êtes de le faire
moi je vais essayer dans les textes
qui émanent des propositions
de l'exécutif de le mettre mais c'est un
réflexe que chaque parlementaire devrait
avoir un alinéa d'adaptation possible
avoir comment c'est comme ça qu'on
progressera sur les outre-mer
enfin favoriser l'insertion le
rayonnement européen et international
des territoires dans leur bassin
géographique
l'Europe j'ai parlé des normes mais
l'Europe c'est c'est notre famille même
quand on est à Marie pasula
même quand on est à marie-pasoula et
l'outre-mer est une chance pour la
France je l'ai dit mais pour l'Europe
et on est maintenant près de départ
de nos amis d'outrement les seuls à
avoir cette capacité forte un peu les
Pays-Bas cela va cette capacité cette
feuille de route s'inscrit dans la
démarche que le Président de la
République a résumé et annoncé
lors de la réunion de travail avec les
élus ultramarins le 7 septembre
à l'Élysée il s'agit de trouver les
voies d'une action publique plus
efficace face aux problèmes du quotidien
de compatriotes ultramarins
la première ministre vous l'avez rappelé
chez le président tiendra un comité
interministériel des Outre-mer d'ici à 6
mois pour acheter une première série de
décisions
à l'issue de ce travail je dis bien à
l'issue de ce travail
il sera possible d'évaluer les besoins
d'évolution institutionnelle
qui devront s'appuyer sur les principes
des évoqués d'adaptation de
différenciation de responsabilisation
mais pas pour satisfaire je ne sais
quelle idée pour permettre un
développement économique plus ambitieux
un rayonnement plus efficace de chacun
des Outre-mer
dans cette optique
le travail avec les élus en général les
parlementaires en particulier sera
essentiel moi je ne me sens pas soumis à
l'opinion publique je suis pas venu pour
ça je ne crois pas aux indignations
numériques et je ne me fie pas au débat
des chaînes d'infos je crois en la
démocratie représentative c'est-à-dire
le dialogue entre le gouvernement et les
parlementaires
je sais que le Sénat entamera la semaine
prochaine une étude sur l'évolution
institutionnelle des Outre-mer
je me permets de dire
dans l'esprit du gouvernement et je
pense que vous le partagez ça ne peut
être que la résultante de travaux sur
une plus grande efficacité de l'action
publique c'est ça qui compte au profit
de nos concitoyens il y a pas
d'absolu ni avant ni après ni avant ni
après
une autre est en cours c'est pas du même
niveau sur les déchets
et on y répondra
je vais vous dire chacun de vos rapports
que je trouve parfois trop long mais il
y a les synthèses on peut pas lire
quatre apports de 80 pages par jour ce
qu'on reçoit
mais les synthèse
mes conseillers et je sais il me le
disent chacun de vos rapports sert à
enrichir la réflexion de mes conseillers
et à tracer non seulement des voies de
réflexion mais souvent des voies de
l'action je souhaite pouvoir non
seulement y contribuer vous pouvez
toujours interroger les services
c'est-à-dire la dgom
et je souhaite derrière mon inspirer je
pense que la composition l'idée même de
ce qu'est le Sénat
dans notre démocratie représentative
sera et sera au cœur du renouveau des
Outre-mer dans les raisons les sujets de
compétences que de simplification
oui je compte sur votre aide et votre
soutien et c'est dans ce sens là que je
le dis
Adolphe Thiers disait la République et
le gouvernement qui nous divise le moins
faire vivre la République dans tous les
territoires dans toutes les îles de
l'archipel France c'est bien ambition
républicaine que nous devons voir pour
nos outre-mer mais ce texte-là se je
veux le répéter parce que ça
me semble-t-il ça rassemble et ça nous
pousse à l'action c'est ce que je veux
faire avec vous monsieur le président
merci monsieur le ministre pour le bon
déroulement de cette audition je propose
de fonctionner par vague successives de
quelques questions pour regarder une
certaine dynamique et vous permettre de
répondre à nos collègues qui vous
interpelleront et éviter la quinzaine de
questions successives on va adopter un
mode un peu plus dynamique si vous en
êtes d'accord moi c'est le ministre mais
cinq questions c'est bien ça me laisse
le temps de préparer les réponses parce
que comme j'ai pas les questions donc je
vais mettre en retourner vers mes
collègues pour ceux d'entre eux qui
veulent commencer à ouvrir le bal des
questions Annick Pétrus pour commencer
bonjour à tous monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre Michel collègue
nous le savons tous la question du
logement d'outre-mer est en effet au
centre des attentes et des
préoccupations dans des espaces
contraints de nos populations en effet
le logement besoin fondamental figure
généralement parmi les premiers postes
de dépenses des familles malheureusement
en l'absence d'antenne de l'Insee le
territoire de Saint-Martin se trouve
depuis presque 15 ans dans un angle mort
les politiques publiques celle du
logement n'y échappe pas aussi forte de
données précises à Saint-Martin il peut
apparaître très difficile de disposer
d'un panorama exhaustif de
caractéristiques du logement sur le
territoire nonobstant cela la situation
des logements c'est Martinois présente
des singularité des vulnérabilités
spécifiques ces faiblesses structurelles
ont été le sur quoi amplifiés par les
effets du cyclonir ma survenu il y a
maintenant cinq ans nous sommes comme
vous le savez collectivité d'outre-mer
relevant de l'article 74 depuis 2007
nous avons récupéré les compétences de
l'urbanisme de la construction de
l'habitation et du logement en avril
2012 la situation du logement social à
Saint-Martin singulière entrez identité
et spécialités législatives le logement
est une compétence de la collectivité
alors que le social relève du droit
communal par conséquent c'est Martin
depuis 2012 ne bénéficie plus de
dispositif nationaux d'aide à la pierre
par exemple elle ne dispose plus de la
fameuse LBU octroyée sur crédit du
ministère des outre-mer et ne bénéficie
pas non plus de dispositifs financiers
octroyés par l'État au titre de la RHI
rénovation de l'habitat insalubre la
collectivité n'est pas davantage
éligible au dispositif mensuel dans le
cadre des plans logements outre-mer
établi en 2016 et en 2019 par le
ministère des Outre-mer en revanche on
ne peut que se féliciter la collectivité
bénéficie toujours des dispositifs
nationaux d'aide à la personne c'est à
dire des allocations de logement
cependant à ce jour la collectivité de
Saint-Martin n'a toujours pas pu
s'approprier cette compétence logement
au sens large
u égal à l'importance du travail à
accomplir recensement élaboration de
textes la collectivité aurait dû
solliciter les services de l'État
aujourd'hui le transfert de la
compétence logement n'a absolument pas
été compensé par l'État il en résulte
pour le territoire de Saint-Martin un
déficit de logement social mais aussi le
logement intermédiaire crucial pour
loger nos fonctionnaire pour ma part je
reste convaincu que nous devons refonder
les cadres d'action de la politique du
logement à Saint-Martin avec l'aide de
l'État par le biais de conventionnement
sous les programmes spécifiques enfin il
pourrait être possible de bénéficier à
l'instar de la collectivité de
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon de crédit
d'État au titre de la RHI
en insistant sur l'angle de la santé
publique de compétences étatiques la
problématique du logement insalubra
Saint-Martin justifierait un effort
supplémentaire de l'État et
l'attribution d'une dotation au titre de
la RHI monsieur le ministre ma question
est la suivante l'État est-il prêt à
nous accompagner sur ce dossier crucial
pour la population saint-martinoise je
vous remercie merci Monsieur Georges
passion
mais bon vous aimez souvent
référence archipel pour qualifier la
France et ses territoires d'outre-mer
par curiosité je viens de regarder sur
sur le dictionnaire dans mon iPhone et
voilà ce qu'on dit de l'archipel
c'est un ensemble d'îles
relativement proche les unes des autres
la proximité se double plus souvent
d'une origine géologique commune
en général volcanique
bon vous voyez où je vais venir c'est
sûr c'est juste c'est pas du tout le cas
de la Guyane qui peut être singulière
dans cet archipel parce que
pas d'origine volcanique c'est sur le
continent et c'est une grande superficie
alors ça explique peut-être que dans
cette archipel la Guyane devrait être
prise à part et traiter à part
pas dans l'ensemble des mesures qui très
souvent sans prise de façon uniforme
pour tous les outre-mer
ça c'était mon premier point le deuxième
point vous nous avez renvoyé la balle en
disant que nous étions les législateurs
et l'adaptation devrait passer par tout
et qu'à chaque texte devrait être laissé
la possibilité pour les autres mères de
faire les adaptations nécessaires mais
quand dans la majeure partie des textes
importants pour les outre-mer on nous
renvoie à des ordonnances
c'est pas évident
puis troisième point l'offre de mer
je sais que c'est sur la feuille de
route du gouvernement bon mention n'est
pas faite encore à l'offre de mer dans
ce PLF 2023 mais je sais qu'on en parle
à tel enseigne par exemple hier j'ai dû
répondre à un journaliste il me
demandait si tu es pour quand la
suppression de l'octroi de mer parce que
c'était dans l'air du temps qu'est-ce
que ça en est contre quand on connaît
l'importance de l'autre de mer pour les
collectivités les communes surtout nous
promet est-ce que l'État sera prêt à
se situer à l'octroi de mer le montant
qui est d'évolue aux communes je crois
un milliard de 100 millions le pouvoir
local puisqu'on parle de différenciation
d'autonomie qu'on pouvait avoir avec
cette taxe quand l'aura si on la
remplace par une TVA
voilà
écoutez pour l'instant on prend deux et
puis les autres vont se décider
patient la Guyane était une île
la forêt amazonienne est-elle plus
facile
à traverser un circulé qu'à l'océan je
crois pas c'est potentiel que démon plus
jeune âge on m'a appris que la Guyane
était quasiment une île en ce sens où
elle est entourée
on parle de l'île de Cayenne puisque
l'Amérique
[Musique]
pour moi de dire que la Guyane est une
île en tout cas elle est entourée par un
une mère verte aussi difficile à
franchir qu'une merde bleue
sur le l'octroi de mer et c'est la
question
je pense que comme vous l'avez dit c'est
un peu la mode journaliste le mot était
lancé l'évolution suppression de
Notre-Dame
ce sont des réformes éventuelles qu'il
faut prendre avec une grande prudence je
rappelle que l'octroi de mer
fournit des R7 à la région et aux
communes
2 est un outil
de politique économique majeures
je pense qu'on a pas assez d'ailleurs
insisté sur un certain nombre de
territoires sur cet outil économique sur
cette capacité à orienter à protéger à
échanger
et donc sur l'octroi de mer
gouvernement et favorable à une
réflexion collective et si nécessaire
avec des adaptations des
différenciations à des évolutions sur
nos trois mères mais peut-on parler de
l'octroi de mer sans parler de
l'électrification du parc de véhicules
par exemple
sans regarder l'ensemble des autres
recettes fiscales ou para fiscales qui
qui font vivre ces collectivités moi je
me refuse à parler de croix de mer si on
ne parle pas de la taxation des
carburants du l'électrification du parc
du véhicule d'un certain nombre de
sujets comme ça donc oui il nous faut
accepter me semble-t-il de le mettre sur
la table
on peut le mettre sur la table c'est une
évidence aller trop vite en la matière
nous assure qu'on fera des bêtises donc
c'est dans mon esprit
et un sujet fiscalité d'ailleurs dans le
cadre des suites de l'appel de
Fort-de-France et du 7 septembre et du
dîner du 7 septembre
un mot d'explication sur la suite du 17
septembre
elles sont consignées elles seront
consignées par
mini intérieur du trimestre d'avronnin
et moi-même elles sont sur le bureau du
Christ de l'Intérieur depuis trois
quatre jours comme il est par monté par
vous il n'a pas signé donc mais je ne
pouvais pas l'état d'âme elles sont
prêtes elles ont été négociées regardées
pour tenir les délais ma réponse sur
l'octroi de mer prudence c'est dans
l'ensemble de la fiscalité et cette doit
être négociée et discutée ça peut pas
venir comme ça il y a tellement de
considérations qui vont autour dont la
principale pour moi et la création de
valeur l'octroi de mer est un outil
économique considérable j'ajoute que
c'est ça peut aussi être un outil entre
guillemets écologique on peut imaginer
les différenciations qu'il était à la
Creuse le plaidait des tarifs de croix
de mer selon la performance
environnementale tel ou tel produit
vous m'avez interrogé aussi sur les
ordonnances sur les ordonnances les
ordonnances
dans l'habilitation soit ordonnance on
peut le prévoir aussi puisque
on peut le prévoir aussi et d'ailleurs
sur cette adaptation permanente
c'est pas simple dans le travail
législatif je pense mon boulot mon
travail c'est d'essayer de le rappeler à
ce qui écrivent les textes lorsqu'ils
émanent de l'exécutif lorsqu'ils émanent
de l'exécutif mais aussi de rappeler au
parlementaires d'appeler les
parlementaires à être vigilant là-dessus
je sais que c'est pas facile peut-être
qu'ils adaptations il y a des
adaptations qui peuvent se faire par
ordonnance d'ailleurs il y a des
adaptations qui devront se faire par
voie législative
partager je dirais comme ça et puis il y
a des adaptations qui peuvent se faire
directement
par le pouvoir exécutif sur place voir
par les collectivités régionales donc
je pense que cette idée d'adaptation
progresse
on n'est pas au bout du voyage il faut
qu'elle progresse encore
sur le logement
même la sénatrice un mot d'abord en
dehors de Saint-Martin si vous le voulez
bien pour me permettre de répondre aux
questions il y a 173
000 logements
dans les drones
ma première satisfaction c'est que
le volume de la LBU disponible pour le
ministère de l'Outre-mer progresse et
que la consommation depuis deux ans non
seulement a progressé mais étaler au
taquet on consomme depuis deux ans
toutes les sommes prévues et inscrites
au titre de la lune
qui sont elles-mêmes en augmentation
2021 225 millions d'euros votés on a
consommé un peu plus d'ailleurs la
consommer 245 7
202235 millions votés 2023 239 millions
proposés au budget donc on progresse
doucement j'ajoute que il y a eu la
création d'une catégorie de logement
très sociaux avec un reste à charge
plafonné à 150 euros
nous travaillons dans le cadre je l'ai
dit je le redis
d'un acronyme absolumentrissant le
plombe dans le club 2 il y a un travail
sur les équivalences de normes
pour favoriser les
produits de construction locaux ou issus
du bassin je signale aussi l'adaptation
de ma priserie noble rénoble et
l'éligibilité des logements de plus de
deux ans
nous avons aujourd'hui besoin de nous
attaquer au logement privé
et donc il nous faut travailler plus
sur ce sujet de réhabilitation
globalement sur les logements
le besoin est immense
je le redis deux axes trois axes
principaux
la dynamique des acteurs du monde HLM
la Caisse des Dépôts
Action Logement c'est leur boulot je
recevrai prochainement l'ensemble des
sociétés et acteurs HLM du secteur
dans leur ensemble
il faut plus de dynamisme notamment la
question se pose de qui fasse aussi les
aménageurs quand il y a un terrain qui
puisse faire aménager constructeur
j'ajoute que sur les moyens Action
Logement viennent m'indiquer à ma
demande que les 400 millions qui
restaient non consommés sur les prés
au-dessus de la période
précédente
2022 2027 et 5 années de ne pas avoir
2000 ça c'est la suivante donc celle
d'avant 2017-2022 400 millions non
consommés sur un milliard 100 seraient
reporté sur la période 2023
2028 sans que cela diminue
les autres engagements donc viennent
s'ajouter en capacité de prêt pour les
organisations
de la défiscalisation
de la LBU de la défiscalisation et à ce
volume de près qui est désormais non
limitatif avec ces 400 millions
désormais non limitatif
les sujets principaux me semble-t-il
fait commun
les terrains les terrains et à donner
particulière à Saint-Martin mais j'ai
une donnée particulière
à Mayotte et il y a une donnée
particulière
en Guyane
à saint-laurent-du-maronis on a besoin
considérable de logement donc les
terrains
l'activité des sociétés d'HLM
et les normes
c'est bien les sujets sur les normes de
terrain de jeu
ce qui dans le club 2 doit aboutir avec
la DHP l'énorme au niveau européen où on
travaille c'est difficile de
sélectionner et de bien cibler des
normes européennes qui nous faudra faire
changer il nous faudra faire changer
foncier
énorme sur le foncier un mois par pour
Saint-Martin Saint-Barth qui met sa main
le logement des fonctionnaires à
Saint-Barthélémy c'est 2000 euros par
mois le studio c'est pas comme ça qu'on
trouve des fonctionnaires c'est pas
comme ça qu'on trouve des fonctionnaires
donc ça fera l'objet d'une discussion
forte nous en avons parlées
leur demande déplacement
à Saint-Barthélémy dans la semaine
prochaine peut-être par les dix jours
qui viennent
le logement des fonctionnaires est une
catastrophe à Saint-Barthélémy et dans
quelques autres territoires 2000 euros
le studio même avec la majoration on n'y
arrive pas même avec la majoration
sur Saint-Barthélémy sur la Guadeloupe
sur la Martinique sujet de l'Agence des
50 pages géométriques
il a été convenu d'accord partie que les
terrains qui doivent être propriétés de
l'agence doit être rétrocédé aux
collectivités régionales territoriale en
2025 d'ici là
et ça n'a pas d'intérêt de le retarder à
2025 si on ne fait pas le boulot le
boulot c'est de bien cartographier
chacune des zones
pour savoir les logements qui pourront
être maintenus par dérogation
et pour pouvoir repérer les logements
qui devront être détruits et donc
activer le relogement
des personnes qui sont dans ces
logements c'est ça que doit permettre
le report à 2025 c'est ça la priorité
sur l'activation de
[Musique]
logement
à Saint-Martin
on a un sujet d'opérateurs qui s'agit de
conforter de relancer vous le savez
c'est un des sujets il y a les cinq
empaches géométriques il y a un certain
nombre de trous dans la raquette
Saint-Martin n'est pas éligible elle
n'est pas éligible ça fait partie des
discussions que je veux avoir avec
monsieur le Président muslimton avec
vous-même lors de ce déplacement qui
aura lieu dans les 8-10 jours enfin je
conclus là dessus qu'il y a une
rencontre récente entre la rue
l'Agence nationale de rénovation urbaine
qui s’est rendu sur place et la
collectivité de Saint-Martin
pour voir comment il peut ils peuvent
approfondir leur intervention j'ajoute
que l'intervention en ingénierie de la
rue et fiançable par l'AFD via la
dgom violet
aux ordres et aux instructions de la dgo
voilà ma réponse monsieur le président
merci Monsieur le Ministre les trois
prochains intervenants Marie-Laure
finira Horse Nassima Dindar et victoire
jasmin
après
c'est bon merci le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président chers
collègues alors j'ai deux questions
à poser à Monsieur le Ministre une sur
l'empaillage et une sur la vie des
étudiants alors d'abord leur paillage un
article de l'ordonnance reformant le
code minier prévoit désormais
d'attribuer des sites exploités
illégalement à des opérateurs légaux par
une procédure administrative simplifiée
à mon avis c'est accès facilité peut
être efficace dans la lutte menée contre
les orpailleurs illégaux toutefois signé
par Emmanuel Macron dans l'entre-deux
tours de l'élection présidentielle ce
nouvel article du droit minier n'est
toujours pas appliqué faute du décret
d'application donc ma question
savez-vous monsieur le ministre qu'on se
décret d'application sera-t-il signé
s'agissant des étudiants de la vie
étudiante alors en 2013 les étudiants et
les lycées en guyanais ont manifesté
pour la création d'une université
autonome en Guyane après des années à
dépendre des Antilles pourtant six ans
après l'inauguration de l'université
Guyane nous étudions dépendants corps du
CROUS situés en Guadeloupe vous pouvez
donc imaginer les difficultés
rencontrées par nos étudiants dont les
dossiers sont traités par des personnes
qui
ignorent tout de la réalité guyanaise et
c'est dans le sens de l'histoire que la
Guyane dispose d'un CROUS autonome à
l'image de l'université donc pour le
moment c'est un clouz et une université
de plein exercice se mériterait un CROUS
merci Monsieur miss
nous sommes bien heureux de vous
accueillir ici et je ne doute pas que
vous connaissez déjà toutes les
problématiques qui sont posées sur les
outre-mer j'avais une question sur
l'énergie à la Réunion vous savez que
nous avons du soleil chez nous déjà un
peu un mix énergétique puisque nous nous
avons beaucoup travaillé depuis de
nombreuses années sur les énergies
renouvelables j'avais une question sur
la prime pour le solaire qui existe sur
le territoire hexagonal métropolitain et
qui n'existe pas chez nous pour aider
les plus de 60 ans à obtenir des
panneaux voltaïques et donc j'avais une
question précise sur ce sujet de la même
façon je voudrais qu'on puisse tenir des
assises pour la cohérence énergétique
parce que c'est vrai que nous avons et
la délégation elle a beaucoup rappelé
les rapports
exceptionnels qui ont été faits très
exhaustifs d'ailleurs les possibilités
que nous avons pas seulement à la
Réunion mais sur l'ensemble des
territoires ultramarins à avancer sur la
question énergétique alors qu'elle se
pose ici maintenant sur tout le
territoire national je crois qu'il nous
faut vraiment pour les outre-mer
des assises spécifiques territoire ba
territoire pour inviter les uns et les
autres les opérateurs
l'État les collectivités à se pencher
sur la question énergétique et puis si
vous me permettez monsieur le Président
vous vous venez de rappeler la question
principale du logement dans les
outre-mer il y a effectivement la LBU
nous avons également la défiscalisation
et puis les aides à l'amélioration de
l'habitat et HLM les bailleurs ont fait
beaucoup de choses à la Réunion et
ailleurs mais nous avons et nous
manquons beaucoup de frappes fûts pour
aménager et c'est vrai que l'Europe n'a
pas apporté suffisamment et donc pareil
est-ce que je le crois nous avons et
besoin dans la zone Océan Indien de
sécurité le ministre d'armanet l'a dit
pour Mayotte la Réunion mais nous avons
aussi besoin de développement avec
peut-être un plan et une cohérence à
apporter sur un la construction et de la
réhabilitation mes collègues viennent
d'en parler la prime rénove existe les
collectivités apportent des aides par
exemple département de La Réunion mais
23 millions d'euros pour l'aide à la
réhabilitation des logements anciens
est-ce que nous ne pourrions pas de la
même façon avoir une mutualisation une
cohérence avec les 400 millions d'euros
pas utilisés et si j'ai bien entendu
reporter pour une vraie cohérence sur la
réhabilitation des logements anciens je
pense à Mayotte aussi mais aussi et
principalement à la Réunion où nous
devons avoir 22
000 logements qui sont en état très
dégradés par rapport à l'existant
aujourd'hui donc voilà une une des
propositions parce qu'il y a quand même
des moyens financiers il y a des moyens
financiers monsieur le ministre vous
avez bien raison de le rappeler par
contre il nous manque une vision globale
et une cohérence par rapport puisque le
1% logement c'est sur appel à projet que
les bailleurs peuvent répondre etc donc
voilà avoir cette cohérence là sur la
réhabilitation des logements et sur la
construction voilà
et enfin Victor jasmin pour ceux de
second tour de question merci beaucoup
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues alors je
vous prie d'abord de d'accepter mes
excuses j'étais tout simplement depuis
8h30 en réunion de bureau du Sénat en
qualité de secrétaire je vous remercie
alors Monsieur le Ministre j'attire
votre attention sur la question assurant
siège dans nos différents territoires
j'ai rencontré lundi dernier des
représentants des
des transporteurs de la Guyane de la
Martine de la Martinique qui était
représentée par les Guadeloupéens et de
la Réunion alors ils sortaient de du
coloc de lu nostra et j'ai eu l'occasion
d'évoquer et cette situation alors je
leur ai promis d'en parler à mes
collègues j'ai vu sénateur patient et la
sénatrice finira mais et aussi Nassima
des dents j'ai pas eu le temps de voir
mon collègue Théophile
le sénateur lui-même en fait ceux qui
sont concernés alors c'est un vrai sujet
l'assurance
il y a très peu de compagnies qui
acceptent d'assurer les transporteurs de
marchandises et de passagers face la
première chose mais en plus il y a une
compagnie qui met en extinction tous les
tous les polices d'assurance qui arrive
à leur terme c'est le cas en Guyane et
c'est imminent parce que j'ai rencontré
un transporteur qui est vraiment dans le
désarroi parce qu'on lui signale que bon
ça a pris l'assurance va s'arrêter qu'il
y aura pas d'être un citron reconduction
et il a contacté par anticipation une
autre compagnie qui refuse alors ce
n'est pas lié au fait qu'il ait eu parce
que il demandait s'il avait eu des
problèmes pendant et toute la période
précédente et bien non donc les
assurances aujourd'hui alors j'avais
déjà évoqué cette situation parce que
quand on a travaillé quand il y a eu
l'examen du texte sur le pouvoir d'achat
alors les agences sont excessivement
cher pour ces transporteurs de
marchandises de passagers mais en plus
on les contraint aujourd'hui à
l'illégalité alors ce sont des emplois
directs et indirects qui sont menacés et
je crois qu'il faut vraiment que notre
puissions trouver des solutions assez
rapidement parce que ce qui est vrai le
président pour la fin d'année pour la
Guyane mais ce sera aussi en Guadeloupe
et l'oursin a attiré d'attention depuis
un certain temps donc c'est ce n'est pas
normal ce qui est en train de se passer
et vraiment monsieur le ministre
j'attends pour que vous puissiez
évidemment saisir les compagnies
concernées et je l'avais dit pour les
Antilles il y a une seule compagnie pour
l'assurance des transporteurs de
passagers je ne vais pas citer là mais
je dis qu'il y a c'est un vrai sujet on
incite les gens à se retrouver dans
l'illégalité ce n'est pas normal la
deuxième chose c'est l'emplacement des
éoliennes sur nos territoires en ce
moment même en Guadeloupe il y a des
problèmes alors on a un problème de
foncier alors d'un côté dans la on a des
problèmes de foncier liés aux
chlordicône un peu plus exacerber que sa
grande terre où il y a des terres
agricoles et avec un certain nombre de
projet la gopark sur le territoire de
cap excellence mais aussi l'usine
centrale sur le nord-inter et là où il y
a vraiment un bassinier maintenant il y
a des cultures vivrières et il y a une
dynamique à la fois de la communauté
d'agglo on fait des communautés d'agglo
de 30 vers la souveraineté alimentaire
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui c'est qu'il
y a sur plusieurs GFA l'implantation
prévue d'éoliennes et avec des
conséquences alors que on peut pas
appliquer la législation en vigueur et
même si il faut une certaine
souveraineté également concernant
l'énergie mais on ne peut pas faire
comme si on était sur de très grands
territoires nos territoires sont exiguës
aujourd'hui nous avons de gros problèmes
parce qu'il faut à la fois parler de
l'énergie et moi je suis d'accord pour
qu'on puisse revenir à un système qui
sera beaucoup plus favorable à la
qualité de vie et au réchauffement
climatique on a un certain nombre de
conséquences mais il faut aussi manger
il faut vivre et là les agriculteurs
souvent debout contre l'implantation sur
certains gérés pas sûr certaines
superficie jusqu'à maintenant dédié à
l'agriculture donc il va falloir trouver
les voisins pour apaiser tout cela et
voir quel situation pourrait être
beaucoup plus favorable à la fois à
l'agriculture mais aussi aux éoliennes
et la dernière chose concernant
également le foncier monsieur le
ministre la situation des affaires des
Outre-mer les affaires des Outre-mer
nous bénéficient pas de superficie de
fonciers disponible suffisante pour
permettre les dotations qui sont prévues
par l'État alors les affaires sont très
très grandes difficultés partout dans
nos territoires là où il y a en tout cas
aménagé en faveur de l'agriculture donc
là c'est ce sont des sujets qui sont
liés à l'économique à la qualité de vie
également mais aussi aux vocations de
nos territoires qui sont pour la plupart
en tout cas liés à l'agriculture voilà
monsieur le ministre que j'ai vous dire
ce matin et puis vous avez en partie
répondu à une question que je vais
probablement vous poser tout à l'heure
c'est le choix mais les réponses que
vous avez apportées
merci et nous terminons cette salle de
question par nana tétouani
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre Chef collègue bonjour je
voudrais avant tout associé mon collègue
sénateur de la Polynésie pour vous
remercier Monsieur le Ministre remercier
surtout l'état parce que quand il fera
19h30 ce soir ici à Paris
au pays il signeront la convention avec
l'État pour l'aide que nous avons
octroyé aide alimentaire obtenu tout
dernier mot ici au Sénat il faut aussi
savoir dire merci alors merci au nom de
tous les Polynésiens
au premier lieu je voudrais interpeller
aussi à notre président de la délégation
et monsieur le ministre sur la feuille
de route là c'est un peu le sens de mon
intervention
quand j'entends délégation entre humains
du Sénat réuni avec le président
l'archet qui présente un peu de route
j'entends après le ministre qui annonce
qu'il y a une réunion
à l'Élysée où les acteurs outre-mer ont
été invités et puis j'entends aussi très
loin à l'Assemblée nationale l'autre
délégation
outre-mer enfin pour parler aussi
toujours de la même chose je pense enfin
une suggestion mais en toute modestie
peut-être si on veut parler des
Outre-mer que tout le monde s'entende et
se mettent tous autour de la même table
et qu'on puisse parler de la même chose
évolution institutionnelle tout ce qui a
été cité
dans le préambule de vous interventions
c'est une suggestion monsieur le
Président bon je sais je le mets pas en
cause le travail qui va être mené au
Sénat que je salue d'ailleurs bien sûr
il y a évolution institutionnelle pour
en revenir à ma collectivité Polynésie
monsieur le ministre n'a pas peur ce
matin je vais être brève parce que les
questions
plus techniques budgétaire on attendra
que l'APL arrive ici
au Sénat ne serait-ce que la Polynésie
outre je rejoins je rejoins totalement
ce qui a été dit par mes collègues mais
je pense que nous sommes plus résilients
aux Polynésie française nous savons ce
que nous voulons et nous avons déjà
programmé aussi bien au niveau
environnemental logement ce qui nous
récemment enfin et ça c'est le travail
des parlementaires aussi bien les deux
sénateurs ou nos députés à venir ici à
Paris essayer de gratter quand je dis
entre parenthèses les quelques euros qui
nous reviennent de droit peut-être par
moment ou bien tirer un peu plus sur la
ficelle pour obtenir plus et c'est ça le
travail des parlementaires enfin je
regarde certains rigoler monsieur le
ministre en Polynésie française je
réfléchis on vous écoutant j'étais en
train de réfléchir en écoutant aussi mes
collègues il y a des départements il y a
collectivité moi j'aime bien cette
expression où on dit il faut appeler un
chat un chat certains dispositifs qui
sont applicables dans nos départements
mais pas éligible dans nos collectivités
mais parfois on parle des Outre-mer des
Outre-mer oui il y a bien les
départements il y a bien les
collectivités
d'outre-mer ou surtout pour les
collectivités où nous avons nos statuts
spécifiques aussi
en 2022 je réfléchis tout haut en
parlant de réforme institutionnelle
peut-être monsieur le ministre monsieur
le Président comment faire converger
tout ça
dans un même panier je sais pas je lance
je lance l'idée pour revenir toujours à
ma Polynésie enfin excusez-moi
les chers collègues de questions
monsieur le ministre
couille
de d'une demande en récurrente mais plus
fracassante en 2022 de la prolongation
de du système de défiscalisation
l'aide à l'investissement fiscal dans
nos collectivités mais quand les données
Polynésie française voir laisser Futuna
deuxième question monsieur le ministre
je vous pose la question parce que j'ai
suivi un peu ce sujet de très loin mais
puisque nous y sommes dans la loi de
finances ou plfs peut-être que de
ce que vous avez annoncé
de du retour de l'État
au financement de de la convention de
nos comptes sociaux ce qui s'appelait
avant convention état solidarité mais
aujourd'hui c'est plus pour venir un peu
soutenir
nos comptes sociaux en Polynésie
française ce qui a valu le déplacement
du président friture il y a pas très
longtemps ici à Paris voilà monsieur le
Président mes deux questions ce matin
merci
il m'en a donné 5 pas facile
pour répondre à ma nationalité de la
Polynésie
la réunion du 7 septembre
faisait suite à l'appel de
Fort-de-France et concernée presque ce
sont des systèmes
institutionnels différents
uniquement ne concernait pas l'océan
Indien
le Pacifique nous concernait pas le
Pacifique concerne indien et pas le
Pacifique donc l'été une réunion type
Valentinois les dromes juste les dromes
et pas et pas le Pacifique mais c'est
pas
c'est pas un mépris bien au contraire
pour
le Pacifique
défiscalisation
le sujet lui est collectif donc nous
sommes tombés d'accord avec le cabinet
de Monsieur le Maire et Monsieur le
maire lui-même et Monsieur Attal surtout
qui suit ça pour avoir une réflexion
globale sur la défiscalisation il y a
deux sujets il y a le sujet
de la défiscalisation logement sur
lesquelles le cabinet de Gabriel Attal
pousse sur lesquels nous faisons front
et barrage parce que parce que
si on va vers une budgétisation de la
défiscalisation logement
il faudra se battre chaque année pour
avoir la ligne LBU dans les classes tant
que ça bouge pas ça bouge pas c'est donc
le débat est en cours
mais l'autre sujet c'est de ramener la
défiscalisation djardin et je suis prêt
et on ouvre les travaux pour la
recentrer vers l'investissement
productif c'est clair
c'est bien de faire de la
défiscalisation sympathique des
fiscalisations excusez-moi de le dire
parfois de confort
il me semble et c'est le débat que j'ai
avec tous les présidents collectivités
je vais avoir avec les parlementaires
ce que j'ai dit
leur passion aussi c'est lié aussi on
met tout vers
l'objectif on met tout vers l'objectif
qui me semble-t-il aujourd'hui doit être
un objectif de création de valeur
économique c'est ça qui c'est ça qui me
préoccupe c'est l'impression que c'est
ça que nous devons faire ensemble
sur les comptes sociaux
comme préoccupe
ça me préoccupait je voudrais vous faire
part juste d'une idée qui est la mienne
comment peut-on utiliser je parle de la
sécurité sociale maladie
monsieur le sénateur Artano
vous vous aviez un choix c'est clair
vous êtes dans le système
madame la sénatrice pour de
Saint-Barthélemy
Saint-Martin
er comment peut-on équilibrer des
comptes médicaux de la sécurité sociale
en étant
un petit nombre d'assurer et de
financeurs
peut-on équilibrer les comptes de
Saint-Barthélémy
avec
12000 personnes au moment
où heureusement il y a de plus en plus
de vieux et au moment où heureusement la
technologie médicale s'amplifie écoute
de plus en plus cher
je me suis mis à penser tout fort que de
toute façon à la fin vous l'avez
souligné madame la sénatrice à la fin on
vient chercher ici logique et c'est
normal le soutien de la métropole le
soutiennent la France hexagonale et du
régime général et de la France
au nom de la solidarité alors la
question ah mais je suis d'accord c'est
normal c'est pas un critique ce que je
sais à quoi je réfléchis C'est les voix
de la solidarité
est-ce que ça changerait quelque chose
madame la sénatrice qui a un système de
sécu maladie qui soit directement dans
le système général
ça éviterait que on en parle tous les
ans ça éviterait de faire un chèque tous
les ans
que ça soit dans ta quand j'ai dit ça à
votre
certain nombre de gens sur le territoire
de députés de la Polynésie ils ont
ouvert de grands yeux mais c'est la vie
même pour les piafragés monsieur le
sénateur frosier
la question se pose quelle que soit le
statut ce sont juste des voix
d'une solidarité nationale essentielle
indispensable et naturelle
c'est juste une réflexion je lance comme
ça en tout cas pour Saint-Barthélémy
quand je vais y aller la semaine
prochaine je vais leur dire clairement
voilà peut-être un début de réponse pour
vous madame la sénatrice
sur leur paillage
il est clair que la meilleure lutte mais
vous l'avez dit et je le redis fortement
que la meilleure lutte contre leur
paillage illégal est un orpaillage légal
ça sera une protection de
l'environnement une protection contre
les voyous
le
décret d'application toujours aller moi
je râle aussi sur la durée comme vous on
me l'annonce avant le 1er janvier 2024
j'ai regardé pourquoi ça dure si
longtemps et bon on va essayer d'y
travailler en tout cas
il nous faut aider l'année prochaine
première expérimentation permettra de
tester des modalités pratiques de mise
en oeuvre sur des sites de friche
il nous faut organiser à la fois
d'aller chercher de l'or pour être clair
manière raisonnée raisonnable il nous
faudra travailler aussi sur la fiscalité
ce doit être me semble-t-il une
ressource forte de la collectivité
territoriale de Guyane
je crois qu'on est passé en phase c'est
une illustration de ce qu'on peut faire
en termes d'adaptation outre-mer par
exemple sur le col minier et c'est la
seule vraie réponse à leur paillage
illégal je suis convaincu de cela
sur le CROUS
un CROUS autonome quand on est à 1600 km
soit à peu près deux fois la distance
Paris - Marseille
d'avoir un CROUS autonome assez 100 km
ça me semble pas idiot ça relève pas de
ma compétence mais ce que je vous
promets c'est de saisir ma collègue la
ministre
[Musique]
en charge
des universités en plus je pense je le
dis publiquement je fais c'est sa
promotion c'est une très bonne ministre
qui connaît très bien les sujets je l'ai
connu lorsqu'elle était à Paris Saclay
et j'ai plaisir à travailler avec elle
il y a deux sujets trois sujets un que
j'ai pas compris sur les aides à 60 ans
au plus de 60 ans si je pouvais avoir
une précision vous voilà je connais pas
le sujet et j'ai mal compris la question
sur le photovoltaïque et sur l'énergie
sur l'énergie je rappelle
systématiquement que seule la Réunion
fait approuvé sa PPE que celle de
Saint-Pierre Miquelon est arrivé je l'ai
retrouvé
exactement donc elle elle a attiré on
l'a retrouvé là ce matin parce que comme
j'avais vu votre préoccupation on a
retrouvé mais je vais rappeler deux
trois choses sur l'énergie outre-mer
1 c'est pas comme la métropole la France
et diagonale on ne manque pas d'énergie
outre-mer premier sujet
on ne manque pas d'énergie
deuxième sujet
au-delà du développement
du renouvelable quel qu'il soit je reste
favorable et attachés à l'existence de
moyens de production lourd
si possible Nono charbon Nono fuel mais
plutôt au bio liquide voire au gaz si on
n'a pas d'autre solution à moins lourd
qui est destiné à ne pas servir
c'est-à-dire qui est destiné à ne servir
qu'en cas
d'incident
de risque de coupure des autres moyens
de production c'est le problème de
larrivée en Guyane ou j'espère en
atteint le jugement définitif sur le
permis de construire quatrième jugement
sur cette affaire en attendant les
primes bon pendant les primes
c'est même sujet encore c'est une usine
lourde qui est destinée à ne pas servir
ou alors 700 heures par an maximum pour
permettre de la conductibilité et de la
réponse au risque
pour les autres il nous faut développer
le photovoltaïque enfin le renouvelable
ça soit du photovoltaïque de l'éolien ou
ou des choses originales
photovoltaïques plus hydrogène comme à
Saint-Laurent du Maroni des soins comme
à la Réunion je crois que ça fonctionne
à la Réunion le soir
ou inventer tout ce qu'on peut inventer
et les outre-mer peuvent être des
laboratoires
sur la défiscalisation l'exclusion de
des photos LTx qui est décidé il y a 10
ans je vous dirais que
alors dans le courant général il faut
des chats moitié personnel je suis pas
très favorable je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi la défiscalisation du
photovoltaïque et des du renouvelable
soit le promoteur du renouvelable
s'inscrit dans un appel d'offres de la
creux avec un contrat sur 20 ans auquel
cas
l'avantage de la défiscalisation sera
pris en compte dans la fixation du tarif
donc c'est complètement écrit paulant
la présente aucun avantage pour le
promoteur puisque si là cet avantage
d'un côté pour l'avoir fait quand le
président
le prix d'achat diminue si il souhaite
aller
directement sur le marché
je dirais que les prix
un peu élevés sur le marché restant
raisonnable
fonctionne justifie pas une
défiscalisation
toute façon gagne sa vie aujourd'hui
avec les prix qui sont et d'ailleurs les
tarifs proposés par la creux dans le
cadre des appels d'offres ou des
contrats de gregrée l'un ou l'autre gré
à gré quand il y a PPE ça serait très
bien
font que on gagne sa vie c'est étudié
pour ça avec des
rémunérations des capitaux investis qui
sont fixées par la creux
qui sont les mêmes pour tout le monde
voilà avec des majorations quand c'est
compliqué la creux obtenue d'avoir une
liberté pour fixer cette rémunération
des capitaux investis qui fait que je ne
vous vois pas trop l'utilité si ce n'est
d'être dans le mouvement général mais on
verra
sur le logement je voudrais appeler que
92 vous avez raison il faut essayer de
planifier ça 92% des vacances de
logement sont dans le logement privé qui
nous il nous faut travailler sur le
logement à la Réunion
produire des logements il faut
réhabiliter tout ça et nous essayons
nous essayons de
fonctionner le plus proche avec Lana qui
doit faire un certain nombre d'efforts
pour mieux prendre en compte les
outre-mer la NA ne prend pas assez en
compte les outre-mer et c'est bien
notamment la réunion sur le logement
privé qu'il faut travailler et logements
privés c'est Lana et Lana pour l'instant
ne travaille pas assez bien avec les
outre-mer
madame jasmin
sujet facile
les éoliennes madame
pardon sur les éoliennes
je rappelle que d'un autre côté les élus
tramarins me demandent de que le CDP
soit plus souple
mais la vie est un tissu de
contradiction ce qui est le nombre de
contradictions dans une pensée et le
signe de sa richesse donc là-dessus on
est sereine donc je rappelle aussi je
rappelle aussi que donc le cdp9 est
saisi que les agriculteurs
agriculteurs sur lesquels on implante
soit ils sont propriétaires ils peuvent
s'y opposer il n'y a pas d'implantation
il n'y a pas de déclaration d'utilité
publique qui impose qu'on accepte une
éolienne je rappelle aussi qu'ils sont
[Musique]
partie prenante financièrement quand on
installe une éolienne et que ça va
encore s'amplifier ceci dit ceci dit
vous avez raison sur le thème
on est une île on est donc contraint
entre les règles environnementales la
production agricole et la production
énergétique
c'est
assez clair sans compter les vastes
zones économiques on essaye de faire du
côté de mornado ou d'ailleurs sur cap
excellent
oui mais je doute pas qu'ils seront si
opposés vis-à-vis de leur propriétaire
et laisser des pénaves sont là pour ça
mais c'est vrai qu'à cette réflexion il
y a des schémas
je laisse les élus locaux feront comme
il
ne s'appliquent pas comme ici
la vie conforme qui est opposé et
opposable dans nos différentes
territoires ici c'est pas appliqué de la
même manière et c'est pour cela que les
élus ne comprennent pas cette façon
d'appréhender les choses différentes
voilà
j'ai regardé les pédales mais chaque
fois que j'ai un élu il me dit laisser
des pédales il y en a marre qui nous
empêchent de faire des choses justement
parce que les services de l'État qui me
donne un avis
les élus voilà
la composition du cdp-9 oui parce que ce
sont les services de l'État qui
supplante qui décide et cette
contradiction et cette incohérence pense
un certain nombre de problèmes donc là
les élus voudraient bien avoir
l'autorité en quelque sorte je veux dire
à ma manière mais il faudrait pour
l'instant et c'est ce qui est demandé
par l'association des mers notamment et
la plupart des élus ne comprennent pas
que ici dans l'Hexagone il n'y est pas
les mêmes contraintes donc c'est deux
pas de mesure de façon simple je vais
laisser des p-9
oui monsieur le ministre on regarde et
on vous répond
sur les
assurances
le problème que j'ai rejoint le vôtre
c'est l'existence d'assureur performance
sur chacun des territoires à la fin il
faut qu'il y ait des assureurs
performants j'ai rencontré hier matin la
Fédération des assurances sans savoir
que vous poseriez la question mais elle
est lancinante elle est lancinante elle
est réelle nous sommes convenus d'avoir
très vite ils en ferai part au
parlementaire une étude précise sur qui
sont les assureurs actifs dans chacun
des territoires et sur chacun des
risques et sur chaque année
c'est pas mauvais sur l'assurance
individuelle
des avec en différenciation l'assurance
automobile pour les professionnels et
les particuliers
l'assurance des industries des activités
économiques et l'assurance et dire du
domicile hein tout ça et c'est cette
photographie que j'ai demandé parce
qu'il faut qu'il y ait plus d'opérateurs
il faut attirer les opérateurs alors une
fois qu'on aura le c'est ça qui nous
manque c'est clair c'est ce qui se passe
que vous avez évoqué une fois qu'on aura
cette photographie je prendrai mon bâton
de pèlerin mais je la donnerai à tous
les parlementaires pour aller se battre
pour maintenir des assureurs et voir
quelles sont les conditions à mettre en
œuvre pour que il y a une offre
assurantielle qui existe c'est bien le
sujet c'est celui de l'offre
assurantielle puisque Edith on arrête
sans pied de raison j'allais dire
politico alcoolique
c'est pour ça qu'on vous retire la
possibilité de vous assurer donc voilà
c'est ma réponse souci commun et déjà un
premier contact avec
la Fédération des assurances et un
premier travail que je leur ai demandé
sur la climonie on est d'accord sur
l'analyse du sujet c'est
qu'il faut que nous assureurs restent
reste présent sur l'ensemble des
territoires
merci Monsieur ministre j'ai donc si
ça affaire vous n'avez pas répondu mais
vous pouvez me répondre ultérieurement
mais c'est un sujet très sérieux
également désolé monsieur le Président
non mais je vous réponds si je vous ai
pas répondu c'est volontairement c'est
que j'avais rien à dire alors je
préférais de dire que j'avais rien à
dire sans rien dire
vous me le fait de dire et donc je
travaillerai là-dessus
merci donc six intervenants encore
inscrits je propose de faire d'abord 4
intervenants puis deux donc Micheline
Jacques
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
j'interviendrai dans un premier temps ma
qualité de rapporteurs sur nos travaux
sur le logement social il préconisait
l'organisation d'assises du logement et
notamment en vue d'une acclimatation des
normes il vous favorable monsieur le
ministre et pour en compter sur une
indispensable implication
interministérielle à cet effet et je
tiens à rappeler que pour avoir
rencontré le ministre du Logement de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie c'est une demande
très très forte aussi de leur part
deuxième point
je rebondis sur la Caisse de Prévoyance
Sociale donc à Saint-Barthélémy de
caisse de prévoyance sociale
affiche un excédent de plus de 20
millions d'euros et j'attends avec
impatience le rapport du gouvernement
qui est prévu par la loi 3DS pour nous
servir de base de travail et ces
résultats sont liés principalement à la
bonne santé économique de l'île d'où
l'importance de la préserver
[Musique]
puisque ma collègue effectivement est
déjà intervenu sur un certain nombre de
sujet et en particulier lié au
développement économique et à la
protection sociale que je partage
peut-être deux points sur lequel je
voudrais
vous sensibiliser et recueillir votre
avis monsieur le ministre le premier
c'est que j'ai eu le plaisir et je sais
que votre cabine a pu le recevoir aussi
donc d'accueillir monsieur le Cyril
tétouané le président des maires du
syndicat des maires Polynésie
l'uspcpf pour plusieurs sujets
techniques et
il viendront bientôt au Congrès des mers
notamment porteur d'un projet
d'adaptation du CGCT
puisque la question s'était posée auprès
de nos maires polynésiens de suivre
éventuellement le chemin qui a pris la
Calédonie d'avoir un code des communes
particuliers
et nous avons avec ma collègue sénatrice
plutôt poussée pour rester dans le droit
commun mais par contre de pouvoir
adapter un certain nombre de disposition
du CGCT au travers peut-être d'un titre
Polynésie française que nous pourrions
enrichir
pour tirer effectivement les leçons de
son application tenir compte des
particularités et Dieu sait s'il y en a
un géographique
de nos communes en Polynésie française
avec le système de communes associés où
nous avons parfois 4 à 5 heures de mer
entre différents atolls qui font partie
de la même commune
et je ne vais pas là à vous détailler
l'ensemble des propositions d'évolution
mais c'est un soin important qui est
porté par les communes et bien sûr les
sénateurs sensibles et je souhaiterais
avoir votre avis voilà sur la méthode
que nous pourrions adopter pour
travailler sur ce sujet dans la mesure
où un projet en tout cas les désiderata
et les attentes des communes devraient
se traduire par un projet de texte qui
nous sera transmis dans le courant du
mois de novembre voilà que nous n'avons
pas aujourd'hui donc je n'ai pas
aujourd'hui d'idées sur la maturité du
texte et son comment dire et la manière
dont nous pourrions le travailler et en
tout cas sur le travail qui reste à
fournir mais en tout cas je voulais vous
attirer votre attention sur cette
échéance et sur la méthode que nous
pourrions déployer ensemble
deuxième sujet c'est que j'ai eu le
l'honneur et le plaisir aussi donc le 4
octobre de présenter le rapport sur la
mission d'information sur les grands
fonds marins donc du Sénat demander par
le groupe RPI et
à laquelle auquel d'ailleurs ont été
associés beaucoup de mes collègues ici
présents
monsieur Berville donc est venu donner
la position effectivement du
gouvernement et nous avons eu des
échanges fructueuses très intéressants
sur ce sujet passionnant
sujet passionnant d'autant plus qu'on ne
connaît pas grand chose en fait de ces
grands fonds et
vous le savez avec une course et de
compétiteurs internationaux comme la
Chine les États-Unis la Russie qui ont
pris une certaine avance en fait déjà à
l'étape de l'exploration et notre
rapport a conclu bien sûr sur le
caractère prématuré de l'exploitation
éventuelle de ces grands fonds
d'ailleurs en droit de lignes de la
position du président de la République
prise à Lisbonne confirmée à Lisbonne
récemment par contre nous pensons que si
la France aujourd'hui a une avancée de
recherche mais aussi d'innovation elle a
besoin qu'on de consolider son tissu
industriel et nous devons profiter du
fait
puisse être lancée à une échelle
nationale pour pouvoir justement
rattraper quelques retards que nous
avons constaté en tout cas dans le cas
de la mission d'information c'était
l'occasion bien entendu de rappeler que
les 97% de la Z nationale sont ultra
marines
et que au-delà de la course
internationale dans la zone
internationale et notamment Clarion
Clipperton ou l'Atlantique nous avons
possibilité peut-être de travailler sur
notre Z2 pour mieux la connaître la
colonne d'eau les grands fonds
ce qui
appelle pour les collectivités du
Pacifique très certainement des
partenariats noués avec nos
collectivités eu égards aux lois
organiques et au statut que nous avons
effectivement dans le Pacifique mais je
sais aussi que dans le cas des drones il
y a un vrai intérêt aussi sur ces sujets
là
ma question aussi est une question de
méthode puisque effectivement c'est le
secrétaire d'État à la mer aujourd'hui
qui a été notre interlocuteur en tout
cas pour ce rapport de mission mais
compte tenu de la place des Outre-mer
sur cette problématique est-ce que vous
envisagez de pouvoir coordonner une
partie de ce volet avec le secrétaire
général la mer le secrétaire d'État à la
mer au titre des outre-mer et une
question peut-être un peu plus précise
je m'en arrêterai là est-ce que on
pourrait imaginer que dans le cas des
appels à projets qui sortent dans le
cadre de France 2030 nous pourrions
avoir une déclinaison ultramarine parce
que c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui le premier
appel à projet il faut s'en réjouir qui
a été lancé il y a quelques semaines
concerne effectivement
les matériels nécessaires l'innovation
technologique pour pouvoir aller dans
ces grands fonds mais nous savons aussi
que des missions pour en faire l'objet
d'une deuxième phase et
pourquoi pas sous réserve de l'accord
des exécutifs des différentes
collectivités si je parle du Pacifique
mais faire aussi de nos pards océans des
océans de solutions en la matière merci
beaucoup
Dominique théophile
oui monsieur le ministre que je voudrais
faire trois points d'attention
sur ces sujets le sujet concernant la
l'étude en cours du projet de loi
concernant l'accélération des énergies
renouvelables vous savez que le
gouvernement prévoit dans la dans le
texte un tarif réduit de l'électricité
au consommateur situé à proximité des
centrales solaires et des parcs Aurélien
on a y en Guadeloupe chez nous une
centrale géothermique il y en a deux en
France de plus de 12 mégawatts dans
la centrale de bouillante et dans le
texte on ne prévoit pas le dispositif de
tarifs réduit de l'électricité au
consommateur situé pour les questions de
[Musique]
difficultés concernant le bruit bref les
les
dispositions qui sont contenues pour les
centrales solaires sont exactement les
mêmes pour les centrales géothermiques
donc une attention pour que dans la dans
le texte de base qu'on puisse introduire
les centrales géothermiques au moins les
ça va concerner deux depuis de 12 mai de
12 mégawatts c'est une demande forte
qu'on voudrait faire puisque ce sera
difficile de revenir après sur ce sujet
là concernant les les contrats de
redressement outre-mer
il a un vrai sujet puisque sur le Corum
et d'ailleurs qui se sont à l'initiative
de nos deux parlementaires
le sénateur patient et le député
Cazeneuve ce sont des recommandations ça
a été mise en place mais il notamment en
Guadeloupe c'est vrai aussi pour
d'autres territoires je suppose trois
communes ont pu bénéficier alors que il
y a des demandes une demande forte et
qu'il faut regarder de très près
notamment
la commune de Grand-Bourg de
Marie-Galante qui souffre déjà de la
double triple insularité pas de double
insularité
et par rapport bien évidemment à
au lien qui existe entre ces trois
communes voir en tout cas double
l'insularité j'ai corsé un peu
mais retenez double et donc difficultés
grandissante
regardez ça de très près pour les
contrats de redressement outre-mer et
notamment la commune de sainte-roeux je
ne cite que ces deux communes
et puis on vient de parler les 50 pages
géométriques ça fait l'objet d'un
amendement que j'ai fait passer dans le
cadre de
qui devait normalement être inscrit sur
la loi de 3DS et qu'on a anticipé sur le
report de
la vie des des 50 pas
qui qui sont financés l'agence est
financé par la taxe spéciale
d'équipement qui est destiné à c'est la
principale sous ce ressources de ces
agences et elle s'établit en moyenne à
un million 100 et depuis 2015 on
constate une diminution chaque année de
la de cette de cette enveloppe alors que
la loi climat est résilient c'est venu
accroître l'émission des agences et
encore une fois justement les sept
prochaines années regarder le texte de
les voir les dispositifs qui sont
demandés aux agences et donc veiller à
ce que c'est pour cette prochaine année
qu'il y a un arrêt de cet écrêtement
pour permettre à l'agence de pouvoir
répondre aux exigences qui sont
demandées avant la fin de la mission en
et enfin Vivette Lopez
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre je ne vais pas revenir sur
ma question d'hier au soir sur la
formation des jeunes ultramarins pour
les inciter à se tourner vers les
métiers de la mer même si cela me paraît
vraiment très important pour la
souveraineté maritime des Outre-mer je
voudrais rebondir sur ce que vous avez
évoqué tout à l'heure les normes
effectivement il y a quelques années
sous la présidence de Monsieur Magra on
l'avait fait un rapport sur les normes
dans le BTP dans les autres mères et on
s'est rendu compte que même quand vous
êtes un autre mère si vous êtes à
Saint-Pierre et Miquelon ou si vous êtes
à la Réunion ça ne peut pas être du tout
la même chose et donc certaines normes
françaises ou européennes ne peuvent pas
être applicables dans ces territoires
pourtant il existe des bureaux d'études
des laboratoires qui ont des solutions
je n'en prendrai qu'un seul exemple qui
m'avait vraiment frappé ce sont les
termites les termites outre-mer n'ont
rien à voir avec les termites de ce que
nous avons en France et les produits
utilisés par rapport au normes ne sont
pas du tout adaptés à cela alors que il
y a des bureaux d'études ou des
laboratoires qui ont des solutions mais
cela revient excessivement cher parce
que quand ils ont trouvé la solution il
faut qu'il envoie à Paris de Paris en la
voie Bruxelles l'envoient à la
commission chargée de s'occuper de cela
la commission renvoie Bruxelles à Paris
cela coûte excessivement cher donc tout
à l'heure vous avez évoqué qu'il fallait
tenir compte des laboratoires qui sont
ultra marins je pense qu'effectivement
il est très important de tenir compte de
ses laboratoires ça va être obligé de
faire tout ce système qui coûte
excessivement cher ça c'est le premier
point et mon deuxième question
sera sur la vie chère effectivement moi
je me suis rendu il y a pas très
longtemps à la Réunion et je me suis
rendu compte que par rapport à quelques
années c'était vraiment très cher alors
beaucoup de locaux vous disent oui mais
voilà quand on voit arriver un
enseignant de métropole il bénéficie
d'une prime pour la charité de la vie
ici sur notre territoire alors que nous
qu'on est des ouvriers avec des salaires
très modestes on ne bénéficie pas de
prime pour la charité de la vie donc
vraiment qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
répondre ou proposer pour cela parce que
vraiment depuis quelques années c'est
quand même impressionnant je le cache
pas merci monsieur le ministre je vous
laisse répondre avant les deux derniers
intervenants inscrits
sur la vie chère je vais d'abord dire
qu'il y a pas d'explosion il y a
certainement pas une croissance
exponentielle des prix
moi qui ai fait un peu de mathématiques
dans ma jeunesse une croissance
exponentielle c'est juste une vision
journalistique aux médiatique exagérée
de ce qui se passe je rappelle qu'il
exponentielle c'est quand ça croit
chaque fois un peu plus vite à chaque
période d'accord jusqu'à devenir
vertical donc alto mensonges
on a un sujet de niveau de vie outre-mer
le niveau de vie outre-mer qui se révèle
par cette augmentation des prix qui est
d'ailleurs pas plus fort d'outre-mer
qu'en France et de diagonale mais
l'agitation politique au médiatique fait
qu'on parle de croissance exponentielle
des prix les mots ont un sens même
lorsqu'on dénonce des choses il n'y a
pas de croissance exponentielle des prix
elle est même plutôt légère diminution
la dérivée secondaire est devenue mais
il faut regarder la dérivée second
la dérivée seconde est devenue négative
donc ça monte de moins en moins vite
c'est ce qu'on appelle c'est le
contraire exponentiel ça veut pas dire
qu'il faille rien faire c'est juste que
quand on veut travailler on essaye de
caractériser les choses le plus
clairement possible sinon ça ne marche
pas moi quand on me dit une croissance
exponentielle
du coup
je dis c'est pas vrai donc je m'en
occupe pas on a une inflation qui est à
peu près la même
dans les territoires ultramarins qu'en
France hexagonale sur laquelle nous faut
travailler et lutter contre la vie chère
voilà ça je suis d'accord et c'était
inflation nouvelle
vient sur une population qui est
un niveau de vie beaucoup plus faible
avec des gens qui n'ont pas de revenus
c'est ça la réalité et pourquoi les
enseignants alors qu'ils sont de
métropoles qui vont travailler à notre
mère bénéficie de primes pour la vie
chère
c'était pas ma réponse ma réponse
c'était pas le sujet vous m'avez dit la
croissance exponentielle des prix je
réponds c'est des carabistouilles voilà
parce exponentielle ça veut pas dire ça
sinon je m'en occupe pas maintenant si
vous voulez proposer une loi pour
supprimer la surémération des
fonctionnaires bon courage bon courage
allez-y je pense que tous les
parlementaires seront d'accord
on a un sujet de logement par exemple je
l'évoquais tout à l'heure 2000 euros le
studio à Saint-Barthélémy ça c'est un
vrai sujet ça c'est un vrai sujet après
l'autre sujet c'est bien les salaires
outre-mer et pour qu'il y ait des
salaires outre-mer descend en
augmentation à mon avis la seule
solution c'est la création de valeur
c'est la création d'emploi c'est la
création d'un tissu économique qui est
largement insuffisant c'est bien cette
révolution culturelle
cette révolution culturelle
qui est on crée de la valeur
que je souhaite avec vous que le
Président de la République m'a demandé
de faire je pense c'est ça la vraie
réponse c'est ça la vraie réponse sur la
vie chère
pour venir la vie chère je pense que fin
octobre
[Musique]
on aura
la fin du processus ou Dino pouvoir
d'achat
il y a des territoires où ça marche ces
territoires ça marche pas et je veux
rendre hommage aux élus locaux qui pour
la première fois sur ce qu'on appelle la
horrible bqp beaucoup d'entre eux ont
accepté de travailler et de regarder
le sénateur Théophile non monsieur le
dire patiente mais pose la question ont
accepté de regarder les ex
les octroies de mer sur un certain
nombre de produits moi je leur en mage
parce que il faisait pas ça avant donc
il y a une sensibilité une nécessité qui
peu à peu s'impose donc réponse
si un sujet extrêmement compliqué donc
je répète que j'y travaille mais après
je vais donner d'autres explications que
j'y travaille avec la DHP dans le cadre
du plom 2 et
j'essaie de le faire sortir plus vite
c'est des normes françaises et qu'on
veut regarder dans le cas de l'article
349 du traité européen si on peut faire
un petit direct tout ça mais d'ores et
déjà dans le cadre de la révision du
règlement européen des produits de
construction
prévu en 2023 la DHP donc le ministère
du logement en lien avec la dgom à
portée auprès de la Commission
européenne le projet de simplifier tout
ça pour les régions ultra
c'est dans le cas de la région du
règlement européen sur les produits de
construction donc là espoir qu'on
progresse on a inscrit de la
communication la valider et maintenant
ça rentre dans le les trilogues etc
parallèlement
le siège tébé que vous connaissez tous
organismes qui s'occupe des normes EN
FRANCE a finalisé l'étude sur les
premiers travaux d'équivalence entre les
normes CE
et ce qu'on peut faire dans les
territoires ultramarins avec une
première liste de famille de matériaux
importés autour
le vrai sujet c'est que il faudrait
inscrire des marquages je rêve des
marquages rubes plutôt que des marquages
des marquages commissions européennes
communautés européenne pour ces produits
pour faire baisser les prix de la
construction c'est ce qu'on essaye on
progresse donc il y a plusieurs combats
et un combat franco-français pour faire
aboutir
quelques sujets du club 2
élaborer une liste dans le cadre de
l'article 349 sur les matériaux de
construction où là on progresse c'est un
combat titanesque c'est un combat
titanesque raison de plus pour le mener
monsieur le chien Théophile sur les
corums merci de votre question
j'y réponds un j'ai sollicité
l'extension de la procédure Corum je
sais pas si dans l'extension
Grand-Bourg et sainte transition Cambo
de Marie-Galante et s'introse ils sont
en tout cas on a sollicité des
extensions je vais vérifier s'agissant
et j'entends ces demandes avec
bizarrement et c'est peut-être les
signes du succès il y a un certain
nombre de collectivités municipales qui
sont dans le cadre de Corum qui donc
améliore le résultat et comme le
résultat s'améliore du coup elles sont
exclues d'un certain nombre de règles et
j'ai demandé à la DGM de regarder ça
c'est l'hommage du vice à la vertu ce
truc ça peut pas marcher comme ça ça
vous connaissez le sujet aussi
sur le financement des 50
pagesométriques je connaissais pas le
sujet vous avez raison de de me tenir il
faut que ces agences et les moyens du
travail jusqu'en 2025
qui je le répète je crois que est
essentiel
qu'est-ce qu'on fait le sujet c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on fait des maisons des
populations installées sur ces zones il
y en a qui faudra reloger et il y en a
pour lesquels pourront rester mais il
faut une cartographie assez précis et
pour ça il faut des moyens sur les ENR
abouillantes
rappelle que la question c'est quand
même qu'il faut démontrer à peu près à
une étude qui caractérise les nuisances
les bruits les odeurs
[Musique]
il faut vite la transmettre qu'elle a
des jeux C c'est la non c'est le
ministère de Madame Fanny qui gère ça
donnez-nous l'étude
qui caractérisera les nuisances pour
défendre cette position je voulais quand
même en profiter pour dire l'ensemble
des sénateurs qui présente
finalement la satisfaction qu'on a à
avoir bouillante fonctionner ça donne
des résultats fiscaux pour la commune ça
donne de l'énergie ça fonctionne on
avait eu à l'époque un vrai
interrogation pourquoi c'est pas des
entreprises françaises européennes qui
sont là
il faut bien dire que cette entreprise
américano israélienne je sais pas très
bien c'est bien inséré c'est bien inséré
mais sous réserves de votre appréciation
dans la commune et sur la côte ouest de
la Basse-Terre il me semble oui je vous
en prie
[Musique]
par toi la capacité de production et
dans le PLF
il serait souhaitable de voir une
augmentation puisque la société qui
exploite que paye aujourd'hui 20 euros
le kilo water en production à la ville
compte tenu de l'augmentation de la
production mais d'augmentation des prix
ce qui est intéressant je vais proposer
un amendement si c'est pas fait par
amendement si vous pouvez le faire dès
l'entrée une augmentation du
kilowatt-heure pour permettre à la ville
de bénéficier de ce reversement puisque
la ville bénéficie d'une subvention de
en fonction de la du nombre de
kilowatt-heure produit
la ville reçoit de la part de
l'opérateur sur la production sur la
production c'était un combat que nous
avons gagné
et d'ailleurs c'est dans l'attente
c'était dans la loi l'urrell déjà mais
donc le décret ne pouvait pas sortir
puisque un mélange d'appréciation sur la
peau sur taxation de la production
plutôt de la distribution donc on a
rectifié il y a deux ans et le décret
est sorti vous m'envoyez ça si voilà je
vais vous envoyer les éléments
les assises du logement
[Musique]
c'est bien
qu'il me l'a proposé
la réponse 1 je m'entends plutôt bien
avec Olivier Klein donc ça c'est pas mal
on y travaille je reçois les sociétés
HLM dans pas longtemps
oui je suis favorable et si je demande
dès lors qu'elles sont préparées
notamment avec les sociétés HLM avec les
sociétés foncières là
les établissements publics fonciers
aussi puisqu'il s'agitait bien préparé
avec le ministère du Logement et surtout
savoir qui on est invite à savoir qui on
invite l'objectif étant que ça assise du
logement il y a il faut le préparer et
que ce soit très constructif et que ça
soit très constructif
donc j'en parlerai à
Olivier Klein et
le ministre c'était plus sous l'angle de
la construction et de l'acclimatation
des normes parce que la
Nouvelle-Calédonie a développé en
référentiel de normes de la construction
qui est déjà mis en place dans le bassin
pacifique et l'idée ce serait de pouvoir
discuter avec les professionnels de la
construction aussi de manière à dégager
des normes qui pourraient être
applicables dans les territoires
ultramarins aux spécificité à tout au
climat à la salinité enfin et à la
construction en elle-même en fait ce
sont plus les des normes constructions
que le logement en général puisqu'on
s'est aperçu aussi que appliquer des
normes européennes et françaises au
logement entraînent un surcou et ce qui
est ce qu'on a de répéter la plusieurs
fois déjà ce matin c'est le boulot du
CSTB moi je verrai ce que j'ai demandé
au CSTB ce qu'il en pense il faut pas
que ces assises retardent le mouvement
dont ils vont évoquer tout à l'heure
qu'il est lanzouin on a toujours le
risque
le mouvement est lancé sur la réflexion
sur les normes et sur leur modifications
surtout ne retardons pas le mouvement
mais sous cette réserve savoir qui à qui
est le maître d'ouvrage de ces assises à
ce moment-là ça devrait être le siesteb
si c'est sur les normes pour que ça soit
efficace
au friche
adopter le CGCT quelle méthode ma
réponse est j'en sais rien
comme ça
c'est assez simple
c'est pas de l'argent
ça coûte rien
on continue il nous coûte non je sais
pas quelle méthode faut qu'on en discute
voilà je peux pas inventer comme ça je
rappelle que les questions ne sont pas
soumises avant
donc il faut faire de temps en temps
réfléchir un peu sur la mission sur les
grands fonds marins
on connaît pas grand chose sauf nos
compétiteurs
vous vous l'avez rappelé ils sont moins
deux je suis pas sûr que la Russie soit
capable aujourd'hui d'aller j'en sais
rien dans le Pacifique en Afrique oui
mais dans le Pacifique je sais pas
encore convaincu le sujet c'est la plus
grande prudence le sujet c'est la plus
grande prudence une des réponses c'est
la coopération internationale
c'est France 2030 il faut et j'ai pris
rendez-vous là-dessus avec le secrétaire
général
à la mer nouveau je le connais bien
depuis des années et je m'engage
monsieur le Président à faire réponse à
faire compte-rendu si j'ose dire de cet
entretien avec le secrétaire général la
mer dans le boulot je pouvais lui dire
c'est ton boulot de s'occuper des fonds
marins outre-mer c'est pas juste la
Bretagne et le Cotentin
j'entends essayer de le centrer sur les
sujets du travail je connaissais bien
son prédécesseur et vous que vous avez
tous entendu parler de la détermination
de son successeur
donc je pense que
contenu du fait en plus qu'on se connaît
de longue date qu'on a travaillé
ensemble était secrétaire général du
ministère
d'écologie lorsque j'en étais le
directeur de cabinet ça crée des liens
et je compte beaucoup sur lui sur tout
ce qu'on a dit sur la mer sur les fonds
marins
mais aussi sur la défense de la sécurité
sur la défense de l'environnement je
crois que c'est une bonne nouvelle et
Monsieur le
si je peux me permettre un conseil quand
il aura pris un peu plus ses fonctions
je pense que c'est un bon interlocuteur
pour votre commission
finalement le ministre et puis moi je
prendrai ma casquette à la fin pour
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon puisque un
moment donné j'ai deux trois
interprétations quand même quelques
sujets au-delà de la pépu on a retrouvé
qui était en limitation Michel Dennemont
monsieur le ministre bonjour je suis
président
aussi à la Réunion et l'inflation est
beaucoup plus élevée que que en français
hexagonale
à l'initiative de collecte député
quasiment d'euros était prévu pour les
départements et régions du fromage
15 millions d'euros que nous avons
complété au Sénat avec 4 millions pour
les collectivités d'outre-mer je sais
c'est le ministre que la pression est
précise je sais que j'aurais pas une
réponse précise c'est évident vous
n'êtes pas un ordinateur mais voilà donc
les tendances voilà c'est ce que je
souhaitais entendre c'est tout merci
ensuite monsieur le ministre si vous
voulez répondre le nom Gisèle Jordan
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je vais vous poser donc deux
questions en relation avec la mission
d'échec que nous conduisons avec donc la
collègue Viviane Mallet qui n'a pas pu
être présente ce matin dont je vous
poserai ces deux questions
au nom de de nous deux et surtout la
première de ces questions puisque
Viviane Mallet est très attachée à tout
ce qu'il y a à la TGAP puisque elle a
fait plusieurs interventions dans
l'hémicycle donc voilà les les deux
questions que suscite cette mission donc
que nous avons sur les déchets très
intéressantes pour l'Hexagonal que je
suis parce que j'ai pu prendre donc
conscience des gros retards et des gros
du gros différentiel qui peut exister
que ce soit en termes de collecte de
traitement ou de valorisation des
déchets
donc ma première question donc monsieur
le ministre
porte sur une demande qui nous revient
unanimement dans tous les départements
ultramarins celle d'alléger le poids de
la taxe générale sur les activités
polluantes la TGA tapé se veut au départ
un outil vertueux mais dans des
territoires qui ont accumulé de tel
retards et qui équilibrent pas le budget
du service des DG la TGAP est perçue
comme un boulet injuste qui prive
précisément les collectivités de moyens
financiers précieux pour alimenter le
budget général de l'État des réflexions
de la taxe sont déjà été votées par les
outre-mer mais elles sont provisoires et
le taux de la taxe va encore augmenter
dans les prochaines années et donc de
fait le poids de la TGAP la question est
de la suivante que pensez-vous de l'idée
d'un moratoire de 5 ou 10 ans sur la
TGAP outre-mer en fonction de la
situation des territoires ce délai
permettant d'engager le rattrapage
nécessaire et à défaut une autre
révolution ne serait-elle pas que le
produit de la taxe abonne de défendre
locaux pour financer des actions en
faveur de l'économie circulaire sur les
territoires
la seconde question toujours en relation
avec notre mission et bien entendu
toujours sur les déchets est une
question récurrente et pénalisante qui
est celle de l'exportation des déchets
ça c'est quelque chose qui est vraiment
très prégnant puisqu'on se retrouve sur
des territoires insulaires avec des
stocks énormes de déchets qui depuis des
années sont là qu'on ne peut pas évacuer
et on ne peut absolument pas donc
faire circuler cette chaîne et pouvoir
donc envisager la continuation des
collectes et traitements
donc cet exportation bien sûr et
l'écouteuse c'est un coup de gestion
énorme et d'autre part elle est d'une
complexité juridique qu'on qualifiera de
Kaf Cayenne car de nombreux pays
refusent le simple transit des
containers quand ce n'est pas tout
simplement les compagnies maritimes qui
les refusent et je précise à ce sujet
que suivant donc le le
la voix de transport il peut y avoir des
demandes d'autorisation donc totalement
différentes avec des exigences
différentes ce qui fait que au départ on
ne peut pas donc faire réaliser le
transfo le transport
or il y a un autre aspect aussi qui est
celui
qui est celui pardon des dossiers d'aide
européenne au fret pour l'exportation
des dix déchets depuis les rupes et ces
dossiers sont extrêmement complexes à
monter alors il y a la difficulté de
pouvoir donc établir donc ce dossier
qui ne prennent pas en compte la
situation particulière souvent des
Outre-mer dans leur environnement
régional et ça c'est extrêmement
important je pense à ce sujet donc à la
Réunion ou à Mayotte qui aurait intérêt
à développer une coopération avec
Maurice par exemple Madagascar ou
l'Afrique du Sud autant de pays qui ne
sont pas membres de l'OCDE donc ce sont
des deux problématiques que extrêmement
récurrentes je vais pas rentrer ici dans
tous les détails puisque nous nous
rendrons certainement notre rapport fin
novembre qui soulève d'autres
questionnements d'autres disparités mais
ces deux points à ce jour sont vraiment
les qui font résurgence sur notre
dossier et nous souhaitions donc avec
Madame Mallet avoir monsieur le ministre
donc votre
[Musique]
avis sur ces questions et du moins les
petites pistes que nous pourrions
développer
merci enfin le collègue de Wallis
Michael
merci monsieur le Président
sur le ministre mais chers collègues
deux trois questions à vous poser
puisque je pense que toutes les
interventions
mais camarades ont déjà évoqué beaucoup
de points qui nous sont communs
notamment
la Ferté de la vie des fiscalisation
pour le point économique le logement
puisque je peux je pourrais évoquer les
logements insolubles au lycée mais
principalement question porteraient sur
une mission des affaires sociales où
elles se font là au niveau du Sénat pour
préparer et développer la conférence de
santé à
cette conférence de santé a été prévue
par l'agence de santé bien sûr la
direction et
sur le préfet avec les élus pour cette
fin d'année mais je pense que le délai
est un peu court et donc je suggère que
qu'on mette en place cette mission avec
tout ce qui comporte bien sûr c'est des
difficultés pour le début de l'année
prochaine
voilà au niveau des affaires sociales du
Sénat donc je profite de l'occasion pour
aviser bien sûr le président
après avoir
saisi le président de rvpi François
Patriat
et avec toutes les
saisines officielles qui devront suivre
par la suite
voilà ensuite j'aurai également bien sûr
l'évolution statutaire à évoqué monsieur
le ministre mais je pense que comme vous
l'aviez dit en début de séance vous
aurez l'occasion de nous recevoir
peut-être un par un si c'est possible
bien sûr dans vos créneaux et
pour évoquer l'évolution statutaire de
police espionnat qui est un gros souci
puisque avec un peu de
avec des sentiments de frustration nous
sommes la seule collectivité
actuellement
avoir l'exécutif entre les mains du
représentant de l'État quel préfet donc
j'aurais beaucoup à
vous dire évoquer avec vous dans ce sens
là puisque je sais bien que l'assemblée
est territoriale
dans son ensemble dans sa majeure partie
je souhaiterait pas précipiter les
choses mais je pense que il est
nécessaire et indispensable que qu'on
fasse évoluer les choses de manière
positive pour la gestion du territoire
de police et Thomas
d'autre part nous avons d'autres
difficultés comme le système bancaire
j'ai presque honte d'évoquer ici devant
mes camarades le fait qu'on est qu'une
seule banque avec deux guichets de
retrait de
et donc je souhaiterais me faire le
ministre
vous saisir devant mes camarades manière
[Musique]
avec beaucoup d'humilité mais de manière
à faire avancer les choses au lycée
Thomas est-ce que l'État
s'implique beaucoup plus et plus
sérieusement dans cette action de
l'Assemblée territoriale pour faire
avancer le système bancaire et ne
serait-ce que nous faire venir une autre
agence à
puisque ce système bancaire concerne
également le développement économique
avec le privé qui est concerné qui est
principalement victime de
cette seule banque avec l'ouverture des
comptes qui est très déplorable
je pense que il serait intéressant aussi
pour les jeunes couples en quête de
propriété immobilière
ou de construction serait beaucoup très
intéressé pour
cette avance que oui
c'est avancé plutôt pardon
[Musique]
souhaiterais dans ce milieu bancaire
d'autre part
concernant la vie chère que tous les
collègues ont évoqué tout à l'heure
au mois d'août dernier j'ai évoqué au sa
même de l'hémicycle du Sénat
cette fierté de la vie
et donc l'aide au fret qui représente
quelque chose positif à l'avenir pour
les histoires puisqu'on est victime de
notre éloignement
et
bien sûr jusqu'au consommateurs on se
retrouve avec des tarifs pharamineux par
rapport au reste des outre-mer et par
rapport à l'Hexagone bien sûr
je souhaiterais que cette aide au frette
soit élargie ou les eftelons dans
l'exploitation de ce texte de loi
je voulais évoquer également les déchets
le traitement des déchets ou il est un
gros souci aussi puisque on est obligé
de traiter localement mais on n'a pas
les moyens nous n'avons pas les moyens
de traiter localement nous avons du mal
même à exporter les déchets traités par
l'Australie
je pense qu'il faut
une intervention de l'État pour que les
choses soient
prises en compte et plus sérieusement au
niveau de l'administration et ses
services malgré la motivation des élus
on a toujours souci
garder nos déchets sur place
je terminerai monsieur le ministre
avec
vous le savez déjà vous vous êtes vous
avez déjà été saisi au niveau de
l'Assemblée territoriale par pour
un gros dossier lourd en financement
bien sûr
la fonction publique territoriale
nous aurons l'occasion de
travailler dessus et j'invite
votre cabinet vous-même sur le ministre
à avoir un oeil bien vieillant bien sûr
par rapport à cette à ce dossier de
notre territoire et il y a également une
mission en cours à Paris mais je pense
que nous aurons à l'issue l'occasion de
d'en discuter
plus détaillé
merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le ministre
donc j'ai écrit pas plus tard
qu'avant-hier sans savoir comment poser
la question on préfère je vais rapport
précis de qui de quoi qu'est-ce qui va
pas quand il y a pas en c'est
globalement mais mais plus précisément
qu'est-ce qui est répondu à
revendications qu'il doit porter auprès
du système bancaire un sujet précis
avant d'intervenir et je l'ai saisi je
pense avant-hier
au sujet de l'aide je voulais élargir le
sujet global de dessert
qu'elle soit aérienne ou maritime entre
Wallis et Futuna
polarisé là dessus on a un sujet de
dessert
et du prix du prix de la desserte qui
est globalement pour les passagers comme
pour le fret
comment dire
fausse draveiller à ce que personne
n'exagère
et donc il faut le faire
sur les évolutions statutaires je dirais
partout
en tous les territoires
si un truc qui est
j'allais dire très politique
c'est bien exécutif est-ce qu'on garde
un système qui date quand même d'un
certain temps
et j'ajoute que même si le problème est
différent des autres évolutions
statutaires souhaitée par les a au
palaisos nécessairement il sera traité
dans le même paquet
il doit être traité il peut être traité
que dans le même paquet ça simplifiera
les choses
ça simplifiera les choses
sur les déchets je suis pas absolument
convaincu que la bonne technique soit
toujours d'exporter ses déchets la bonne
technique c'est d'essayer d'en avoir
moins et des traités de manière utile à
l'endroit où ils sont
utile à l'endroit où ils sont là aussi
des dès que je vois le préfet je lui
donnais des je viens de le faire en
principe
Mayotte on lui adressé
10 questions il dit sentiment de ma part
sur tel ou tel sujet et qui veut bien
soit traiter soit répondre
sur les la fonction publique
il y a un sujet mais on est déjà quand
même pour vos collègues assez aidants
l'accord qui est trouvé
on paye cher de manière dégressive mais
pendant 8 ans donc peut-être qu'il faut
venir mais à ce stade
à ce stade il y a un peu de travail déjà
fait à Monsieur le sénateurs oui
l'ordinateur que je suis c'est que il y
a eu 15 millions pour les dromes et 4
millions pour les comme alors sur les 15
millions ça donne 250 pour la Guadeloupe
dont 150 pour la grippe Saint-Martin 3,5
pour la Guyane un œuf pour la Martinique
de 6 pour la Réunion 4/8 pour Mayotte
50000 pour saint-pierre-miquelon et sur
les comes un 8 pour la Polynésie 100 000
pour Wallis 2 millions 100 sur la
Nouvelle-Calédonie pour les 4 millions
on essaye par ailleurs de travailler
avec
elle s'appelle l'association La qui nous
donne
la Banque alimentaire pour essayer qui
cible un peu leurs choses et qui fasse
des choses spécifiques
outre-mer
sur la TGAP
je suis pas sûr que ça soit une bonne
solution de la baisser je le dis qui
paie la TGAP des entreprises c'est pas
les collectivités locales c'est quand
même fait pour les inciter à essayer de
produire moins de déchets j'ai pas bien
compris le ce qu'il faut faire avec la
TGV pourquoi voulez-vous baisser la TGAP
aux entreprises ultramarines
une grosse difficulté à faire face pour
pouvoir donc traiter correctement donc
la question et surtout pour pouvoir
avoir une une collecte qui soit de
qualité il y a vraiment un
accumulation d'un des problèmes sachant
que dans certains secteurs
la TGA P n'est pas partout tout le monde
ne ne la perçoit pas donc il y a un
rééquilibrage donc
tu as demandé c'est un cheval de
bataille que Viviane expliquerait mieux
que moi puisque c'est elle qui vraiment
a été à passer des amendements
d'ailleurs l'année dernière qui ont été
donc accepté pour avoir donc une une
baisse de cette chose là mais c'est un
problème récurrent et notamment un
problème récurrent à la Réunion en fait
la TGAP est payée par les communautés
d'agglo le font
ils vont ils augmentent la taxe sur les
ordures aménagères et donc au final ça
reste le citoyen ma collègue et je
remercie ma collègue Jordan d'avoir posé
cette question Viviane m'aller a passé
des amendements
à mettre prise dont une qui a été
acceptée par le gouvernement sur une
baisse de 15% sur le taux de la TGAP
pour la Réunion mais ça n'est qu'un
acquis provisoire et effectivement elle
elle demande avec le groupe LR et Lucie
qui avait voté que la TGAP qui est un
moratoire sur les années pour les
outre-mer puisque la demande
d'investissement dans nos territoires
est tellement important pour les
collectivités
territoriales et principalement pour les
communautés d'agglo que ça impacte
leur budget sur les investissements
apportés et à venir donc oui tout à fait
oratoire c'est pas une suppression qui
est demandé c'est un accompagnement
je veux le comprendre je veux qu'on
évite de produire des déchets c'est
plutôt mon souhait à l'arrivée s'appelle
sur les entreprises qui sont incitées
normalement c'est comme ça que ça marche
inciter à ne pas
à mesure de déchets mais je veux bien
garder mais dire
c'est en France hexagonale ça marche
alors je sais pas si ça marche
différemment outre-mer je vais regarder
[Musique]
je suis surpris voilà je suis surpris
on peut pas dire mieux
on va gagner du temps il faut il faudra
m'expliquer pourquoi il faut
pourquoi ne faut-il pas inciter les
entreprises à ne pas produire de déchets
je prends votre question ma question en
réponse c'est celle-là je comprends pas
donc mais si j'ai compris on peut bouger
quand elle exploitation de déchets
moi je suis pas du tout je ne suis je ne
suis pas une insulaire mais c'est pas
une entreprise elle vous l'a dit c'est
les collectivités qui le paie c'est pas
du tout on n'est pas dans le système que
nous avons donc en hexagone ou c'est ça
pèse sur l'entreprise là ce sont les
collectivités qui se substitue et qui
paient cette taxe là c'est ça le sujet
sur l'exportation de déchets c'est une
affaire globalement c'est pas bien
d'exporter ses déchets globalement c'est
pas bien d'exporter ses déchets
ça coûte c'est intellectuellement
curieux alors sur les déchets un certain
nombre de chez toxiques ça me paraît
possible souhaitable mais sur des
déchets ordinaires c'est pas souhaitable
on a des problèmes de normes on revient
à l'ensemble des normes sur lesquelles
on doit travailler sur les aides
européennes c'est évidemment compliqué
je ne peux que vous approuvez et je
cherche en général j'essaye d'éviter de
les chercher en première approche parce
que
ça coûte beaucoup d'énergie et à
l'arrivée beaucoup de contrôle et je
suis pas sûr que ça marque en dehors de
truc qui est bien calé le fait d'air le
fait adhère le ferme tout ça il y a des
choses simples mais dès que vous allez
chercher des choses un peu originales
type fraffus ou intérêts vous pouvez y
consacrer des équipes pendant longtemps
quand même donc
je vais pas aller le chercher le fraffu
non mais j'ai pas le temps
que je vous avoue que je veux apporter
par rapport à la discussion sur la TGAP
c'est relatif surtout par rapport à
l'enfouissement des déchets voilà c'est
c'est y compris des décisions ménagers
c'est c'est cibler sur une problématique
on va regarder sur la TGAP mais je suis
sceptique voilà à ce stade mais après je
vais regarder
aujourd'hui je serai très prudent dessus
sur la PPE merci pour
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon de l'avoir
retrouvé monsieur le ministre du
président de la collectivité était un
petit peu inquiet
dont cette thématique PPE il y a un
projet éolien à Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon
mené par EDF énergie
renouvelable attention sur la méthode
utilisée on sait que sur des territoires
ultramarins avec des conflits d'usage et
d'espace l'approche qui doit être faite
par les opérateurs toi tu nous approche
de long terme qui allie la population
qui explique les choses et je le dis on
a déjà des projets qui ont capoté et je
ne voudrais pas surmonter et toi
celui-ci capote parce que je suis
favorable à l'éolien mais il faut que
les choses soient bien expliquées comme
je sais que vous êtes impatient de
message je me permets de profiter cette
audition pour vous faire passer ce
message de prudence ensuite les deux
trois thèmes pour
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon le premier
solitaire qui concerne d'ailleurs tout
l'outre-mer un rapport de nos collègues
de l'Assemblée avaient pointé du doigt
les conséquences de la suppression
programmée de l'ittr sur nos territoires
c'était monsieur Dunoyer Gomez je crois
le rapport a été remis à de mon chalet à
l'époque qui terminait son ministère de
la Fonction publique et des réflexions
étaient engagées par le gouvernement
est-ce qu'elles sont en cours est-ce
qu'on peut avoir des perspectives ou
est-ce que ce dossier est tout
simplement enterré avec la conséquence
évidemment pour chacun de nos
territoires d'un départ de
fonctionnaires qui perd le pouvoir
d'achat et quand vous le quand vous le
mettez en parallèle avec la situation
que tu connaissons ou sur la vie chère
et l'inflation je vous fais pas de
dessin à terme donc l'ither là le
premier sujet le deuxième sur sur la vie
chère à Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon oui à
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon à une inflation
galopante quand vous êtes dans
l'Hexagone à 5 58 sur un an chez nous on
est à 9 36 donc nous on peut dire qu'on
a une exposition une inflation qui est
exponentielle pour notre population et
qui est inquiétante et d'ailleurs si si
vous prenez le l'un des premiers postes
dépenses à Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon qui
est le fioul pour une maison de 90
mètres carrés vous étiez à 1500 euros en
2021 vous êtes à 2500 2022 vous sera
2400-2023 si on maintient le prix de
l'hydrocarbure tel qu'il est aujourd'hui
et j'en reviens à la demande qui a été
formulée par le président de la
collectivité lors de la conférence au
pouvoir d'achat organisé par le préfet
et relayé par le député est-ce qu'il est
envisageable d'étudier un blocage du
prix du fioul domestique à 0,65 centimes
d'euro c'est une question sans technique
mais la question est sur la table est-ce
que c'est possible de l'envisager la
deuxième question sur le fioul
domestique à Saint-Pierre mi-temps qui
est le premier poste une aide
exceptionnelle a été mise en place
en lien avec la collectivité
territoriale vous avez répondu au député
l'autre jour à l'assemblée que il y
aurait une évaluation du dispositif
alors je vais vous faire l'évaluation
directe avec assez simple puisque tout
ton blog va être consommé le dispositif
a été conçu en accord entre le
gouvernement et la collectivité pour
qu'il soit intégralement consommé dans
les quelques semaines qui viennent la
question qui était posée c'était
d'anticiper parce que gouvernez ces
prévoir et que l'hiver à Saint-Pierre
mi-temps peut aller jusqu'au mois
d'avril et qu'on couvre à peine deux
mois de consommation pour les foyers
notamment les plus fragiles et tout la
population n'est pas concerné par l'aide
c'est aussi un sujet pour mes
concitoyens est-ce qu'il est
envisageable de considérer que le
dispositif pourrait être étudié
reconduit pour plusieurs mois à venir
c'était la deuxième question au-delà
d'évaluation dont on connaît déjà le
résultat et puis enfin vous êtes
intervenu sur la vie chère auprès de la
compagnie CMA CGM pour un certain nombre
de territoires ultramarins parce que
cette société dessert directement ces
territoires elle ne décidèrent pas sa
pierre-emilton puisque nous arrivons par
ricochet en bout de ligne de dessert et
donc ce sont des opérateurs
internationaux qui amènent le fret au
Canada puis du Canada
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon est-ce qu'il
est envisageable dans le cadre de la
délégation de service public piloté par
l'État à Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon
d'imaginer à dispositif qui permettent
de bloquer peut-être certains facteurs
de la délégation de service public tout
en respectant évidemment les contraintes
juridiques que sont ne pas venir
perturber l'équilibre général de la
délégation de service public vous ne
pouvez pas intervenir sur ces Gemma CMA
CGM pour nous est-ce que vous pouvez sur
l'opérateur local qui est sous contrat
avec
et pourquoi je pourrais pas intervenir
sur CMA CGM parce qu'il n'aime pas sa
pyramidon mais si vous voulez créer une
ligne directe à l'image de celle que
nous avons l'été l'avion
j'interviens tous les jours quasiment on
sera on sera très heureux cas échéant
monsieur le ministre et je pense que
j'en ai terminé il y a quand même pas
mal de questions merci
Ikea
il y a eu un premier comité de pilotage
avant les élections présidentielles il
faut je pense le sujet de discussion
avec Monsieur Guérini que je vois dans
les jours qui viennent je sais pas vous
voulez prendre les uns après les autres
c'est un des sujets de la discussion que
devient le sujet Ikea qui avait été
lancé par sa prédécesseuse
sur le fioul vous avez dit qu'il y avait
combien d'habitants
à Saint-Pierre assimile hein
l'augmentation elle est de 1000 700
000 à mon avis il fait l'année alors
après il faut reconduire mais regardons
c'est pas compris quand vous faites une
arythmétique simple vous dites le
montant de la cuve il est passé de temps
à temps
et à mon avis les 700 000 font le
montant de la cuve de l'augmentation du
coup
ça fait l'augmentation du coup c'est
bien non mais il faut quand même dire
les choses le maire de Saint-Pierre est
venu vous voir tout récemment
monsieur Yannick Cambrai il a eu la même
demande d'ailleurs pour nos concitoyens
tout en s'émouvant d'ailleurs du montant
financier accordé par l'État et disons
sur les ondes publiques je le dis tel
que je l'ai entendu que le ministre
avait été étonné de la demande des 700
000 qui paraissait pour lui est
largement insuffisante
je pense que vous connaissez le contexte
de cette demande budgétaire elle est
insuffisante et on le sait pertinemment
parce que les gens ne passent ne
passeront pas l'hiver avec 700 000 euros
répartis sur le nombre de foyers fiscaux
concernés ça n'est pas vrai ça n'est pas
vrai et ceux qui vous disent le
contraire je pense que effectivement la
science des nombres n'est pas une
science une science infuse mais voilà je
pense super à regarder vous le savez oui
ce qu'il faut c'est ce que je voulais
ce qu'il faut après on va regarder ici
après pour le vos collègues de
l'Assemblée sur le l'énergie électrique
je vous suis juste avec un sourire il
doit y avoir moins de 25 km de route à
Saint-Pierre papa Miquelon
[Musique]
j'ai pas un énorme sujet si on juge il
faut éviter de polluer c'était mieux et
de faire le mieux pour le consommateur
et je doute pas qu'on s'est connaissant
l'esprit d'entrepreneur à Saint-Pierre
il y a un véritable esprit d'entreprise
Saint-Pierre
on va trouver quelqu'un qui va nous
faire ça tranquille
j'en ai aucun doute
voilà
non parce qu'il faudra quand même
exporter les déchets que ce sont des
déchets qui sont compliqués à exporter
quand vous avez des voisins qui sont
américains ou Canadiens donc c'est cet
environnement là qu'il faut avoir à
l'esprit quand vous savez que l'amiante
sur le territoire ne part du territoire
que parce que des bateaux militaires
passent parce que la marine accepte de
prendre ses déchets pour les amis sur
l'hexagone je pense que ça questionne
une batterie donc
amiante batterie et on n'est pas le sol
territoire à la Réunion il y a également
des stocks de conteneurs qui sont
bloqués qui ne peuvent pas exportés
du blocage du prix du fioul à
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon est-ce que
c'est possible d'étudier cette question
il est toujours possible d'étudier une
question
c'est tout quand elle est posée par
quelqu'un de compétent on avance déjà
quand la question est posée
et par la suite comme je sais que vous
envisagez de venir également sur le
territoire Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon et
vous êtes également le bienvenu j'avais
lors de la conférence sur le pouvoir
d'achat avec le préfet fait appel à la
construction d'un pacte territorial pour
lutter contre la vie chère aujourd'hui
seul la collectivité c'est positionné
côté de l'État et je crois vraiment que
l'ensemble des acteurs mais je peux
compter aussi sur votre impulsion
monsieur le ministre devrait se mettre
autour de la table tout le monde doit y
apporter sa contribution pour faire en
sorte de construire un pacte et une
réponse concertée à l'échelle du
territoire en accord avec l'état voilà
je passe le message
intervenants sur la place qui peuvent
contribuer à la lutte contre le pouvoir
d'achat de la publicité c'est ce que je
veux dire
mais ça et ça c'était c'est ce que
chacun peut mettre dans la balance il
faut que chacun mette dans la balance
voilà exactement ce qu'on peut
contribution juste et évidemment le plus
possible voilà en conclusion
3 mois c'est déjà beaucoup mais enfin
dans les trois mois je vais partir 20
jours outre-mer j'ai pris 15 jours même
pas de congé le flou de question est
gigantesque
je sais pas si vous en rendez bien
compte le taux de question est
gigantesque en tentant je suis surpris
de la question
il y a juste un truc peut-être que j'y
mettrais un peu de temps mais avec mes
équipes sous l'autorité de du président
de la République l'impulsion de Gérald
Darmanin
vous devez pouvoir compter et vous
pouvez compter sur le fait qu'on regarde
les problèmes et qu'on essaye d'y
apporter une solution il n'y a pas de
solution miracle il n'y a pas de
solution miracle
la seule solution miracle à terme c'est
la création de valeur c'est mon c'est
vraiment mon leitmotisme et je répondrai
tout ça
il y aurait beaucoup moins de questions
si on y arrive
merci de m'avoir écouté Monsieur Merci
monsieur le ministre de votre
disponibilité d'avoir pu répondre autant
que possible aux questions qui vous ont
été transmis je ne doute pas que le
cabinet continuera à travailler avec les
parlementaires qui ont des questions
autres par la suite simplement vous
rappeler à mes collègues de la
délégation que nous nous revoyons mardi
11 octobre sur l'évolution
institutionnelle outre-mer avec la
première audition donc la collectivité
de Saint-Barthélémy puis le jeudi 13
octobre avec toujours ces auditions avec
madame Huguette Bello donc la présence
du conseil régional de La Réunion et à
10h le 13 une étude sur l'étude de la
gestion des déchets sur le volet
sanitaire une table ronde que la
délégation organise je vous souhaite à
toutes et tous une bonne journée